في «جاهز» وصلنا وهذه حقيقة وليست كلام
أن عميل يتصل يشتكي
لأن المزاز ما وصل مع المشروب
ويجيه تعويض
ما تعتقد أن هذا كأن له تأثير مباشر على حصتكم السوقية
أنكم الثاني بدل الأول؟
من يقول أننا الثاني؟
هذه الأرقام اللي نعرفها
وينها؟ من وين جبتها؟
أنت تشوف أنك الأول اليوم؟
من وين جبتها؟
أنا أسألك، اليوم تشوف أنك الأول وللا لا؟
أنا ما أقدر أصرّح صراحة
بعض الأرقام ما أقدر أصرّح
إذا عندك أرقام، عندك إحصائيات؛ قلها
أنا ضد لما يجي واحد يقول
لازم نسعود القطاع كامل
مستحيل
تجربة الطرح كيف كانت؟
أفضل وأجمل وأسوأ وأصعب قرار
يلا حيّهم، ضيفنا اليوم «حمد البكر»
الشريك المؤسس والرئيس التنفيذي التجاري لشركة «جاهز»
طبعًا شركة «جاهز» أتوقع كلنا نعرفها
وكلنا نعرف تطبيق التوصيل المعروف الخاص فيهم
لكن الصورة الكاملة للشركة
فيها أكثر من كذا بكثير
لهذا السبب اليوم ما راح أضيع وقت كثير
في قصة «جاهز» متى تأسست؟ وشلون سووها؟ وليه سووها؟
لأنها انذكرت كثير قبل كذا صراحة، ولا ودي نكررها
فبدخل مباشرة في موضوع
علاقة تطبيق «جاهز» مع المتاجر
من ناحية النسبة. كيف تتحدد؟
تكاليف الإعلام مع التطبيق
شكاوى المطاعم اللي يشتكون عنها
سواءً على النسبة، على التعويضات اللي يتحملونها
شكاوي الناس على الأسعار
وغيرها من الأمور في الموضوع هذا
ثم ننتقل بعدها نسولف عن تجاربهم في الجانب التسويقي
مثل اشتراك «برايم» اللي سووا له توصيل مجاني
رعايتهم لنادي «الهلال»
تأسيسهم لتطبيق «بلو» بالشراكة مع النادي
حملات استرداد المبلغ اللي عادةً يسوونها بالشراكة مع البنوك
وشلون عادةً يسوونها؟
مين يتحمل التكاليف؟
ثم بغطي جانب الشركات التابعة لشركة «جاهز»
من ضمنها شركة «المطابخ السحابية»
وشركة التوصيل الخاصة فيهم
ومنصة «بِك» للتوصيل من المتاجر
بنتكلم بعدها عن استثماراتهم واستحواذاتهم في مختلف الشركات
وليش طولت محاولة استحواذهم على شركة «ذا شيفز»؟
وليش استحوذوا على شركة «مرن»؟
وليش استثمروا في عدة شركات؟
وبنتختم في نقاش عن المنافسين والسوق وتجربتهم في الطرح
والتعليقات اللي جاتهم على انخفاض أرباح الشركة
وانخفاض سعر السهم
وغيرها من الأمور المتعلقة في هذا الموضوع
حلقة دسمة جدًّا ومليئة معلومات غالبًا أول مرة تسمعها
أترككم الآن مع الحلقة
حيّاك الله أبو عبدالله
يا هلا ومرحبا
سعيد جدًّا صراحة باستضافتك
لنا فترة ترى نحاول ننسق اللقاء ذا
تعرف مدى إعجابي فيك
الله يعطيك العافية
ومسيرتك
بالعكس أبرك الساعات وحيّاك بأي وقت
ما أبي أضيّع وقت
لا في البداية بسواليف ما لها أي علاقة في «جاهز»
ولا في الكلام عن قصة «جاهز»
ما شاء الله قد تكلمت عنها عدة مرات قبل كذا
بدخل بالزبدة على طول
علاقتكم مع المتاجر
وودي نتكلم عنها بتفاصيل أكثر
طبعًا هو موضوع جدلي يصير دائمًا بين الناس
على النسبة، على طريقة التعامل
على المرتجع، على كل الأمور
أو المشاكل اللي تصير في الطلبات
نأخذها حبة حبة
أول شيء النسبة
اللي أعرفه وصححني إذا غلطان
متوسط النسبة عندكم تقريبًا 12%
صحيح
ما بين جميع المتاجر، المطاعم مقاهي، أيًّا كانت
أيش اللي يحدد النسبة بالضبط؟
لأن فيه متاجر تأخذ أقل، ومتاجر تأخذ أكثر
فأيش اللي يحدد النسبة؟
لا، طبعًا «جاهز» تقريبًا متساوية
اللي يحدد فقط وقت الدخول
يعني الناس القدامى معنا لهم نسبة كانت 12%
ووصلت 13% الآن
الجدد 15%
بس ما فيه، أنه والله مطعم كبير، مطعم صغير
متجر كبير، متجر صغير، لا
إلا حالة وحدة فقط في مجموعة
مطاعم تابعة لـ «تسعة أعشار»
هذولا أسر منتجة تابعين لـ«تسعة أعشار»
وكان فيه تعاون بيننا وبين «تسعة أعشار» أننا ندعمهم
فكنا نعطيهم نسبة 6% يوم كانت المطاعم 12%
الآن 8% يوم صارت المطاعم 13%
الباقي نفس الشيء
تلاقي «ماكدونالز» وتلاقي بوفيه في شارع «الصفراء» ببريدة
نفس الرقم
معقولة؟ ما يجي يفاوضك يقولك
أنه والله قاعد أضيف لـ «جاهز» قيمة كبيرة
كلهم يضيفون
أكيد، بس الـ«ماكدونالز» بيضيف أكثر من مثلًا المطاعم
بس صعب لأنك لو سويت فرق بالنسب
صعّبت المنافسة عليهم بعد
اليوم إذا مطعم «إيه» ومطعم «بي»
واحد أقوى من الثاني
وعطيت الأقوى 10% والثاني 20%
قوّيت هذا بزيادة، وبديت تضعّف ذاك
خلّ لك نوع من نوع ما عادي
بس ما قد وصلتوا قبل كذا
مع أي مطعم من المطاعم الكبيرة يجون
اسمعوا يا جماعة قاعدين تكلفوني واجد
أنا قاعد أجيب لكم مطالبات بالحجم
بما أني علامة تجارية معروفة
يا تنزلونها لي 11% أو 10% وللا ترى بوقف
ما وصلت الحالة هذه
يوصل كلام، يوصل نقاش، يوصل بعض المطالبات
يوصل بعض الضغط
لكن ما وصلت أنه والله عطوني وللا أطلع
لا ما جاتنا من أي مطعم
بعدين هي ترى عملية تشاركية
يعني اليوم أنا ما أقول نسبة
النسبة ما هي أتاوة
النسبة اليوم كما الإيجار
أنت فاتح مبنى على طريق الملك فهد
مبنى كبير وتبي تأجر لعشر مطاعم
أو عشر متاجر أو عشر محلات ذهب
هل تحط إيجار هذا غير هذا؟
غالبًا الإيجار هو على قيمة مبناك أنت
وتكلفة مبناك أنت مع نسبة ربحك
لأني أسمع في تطبيقات ثانية
يكون في تفاوت بين...
هي سياسات طبعًا، كل تطبيق له سياسات
بالنسبة لنا بـ«جاهز» لا، احنا نسبة ثابتة
إلا كما قلت لك فيه مجموعة الجدد
اللي جونا بعد ثلاث سنوات من بدايتنا
قلنا لهم: والله لا، معليش اعذرونا
هذولاك أقدم ومعنا من أول
والنسبة شوي ماهي مكفيتنا بالحيل
فرفعناها لـ 15%
احنا نشوف منافسكم على الأقل اللي أسمعه
قد تكون المعلومة غير دقيقة
بس أسمع من المطاعم أن «هنقرستيشن»
توصل نسبه إلى 20%
وفيه حالات قد تصل إلى أكثر من كذا
فهل معناته هذا الحين قاعد يشق الطريق لكم
بحيث أنكم تبدون ترفعون النسب
وتوصلون إلى النسبة هذه؟
أو اختلاف في استراتيجيتكم؟
لا، طبعًا هي شغلتين
أول شيء منافسكم هذه برجع لها
لكن بالنسبة للنسب
تمام أنت تاجر، ودك تاخذ 100% من الربح لك
صح لو تقدر، بس هل هو صحيح؟
مو صحيح، لأن أنا لما آخذ نسبة اليوم
أنا آخذها من التاجر
هو التاجر اللي جالس يبيع
إذا ما يربح؛ ما راح يستمر معي
وبخسره بعدين وبخسر السوق
فأنا باخذ نسبة تريحني وتكفيني وتكسّبني
ولا تضر للتاجر
لكن من وجهة نظرك
على الأقل بعرف وجهة نظر «جاهز»
ليش تاخذ 12% و15% نسبة؟
أيش اللي يبرر النسبة هذه؟
أنا عارف الجواب، بس أبي تجاوب للمستمع
طيب، هذه كنا بديناها من البدايات
ويمكن من النكت، أن أول ما بدينا
كانت تطلع لنا إشاعات
أن «جاهز» تاخذ نسب قليلة فقط
لما تستحوذ على السوق؛ بترفع وتصلخكم
سمعوها كثير من المطاعم
الحمد لله كبرنا وصرنا كبار وطلعنا برّا المملكة
وصرنا *مدرجة
ولا صلخناهم، ولا طلعنا عنها
نظريتنا فيها: إذا ما يكسب التاجر اللي يشتغل معي
أنا ما راح أكسب *على المدى البعيد
بس ليش تاخذ من الأصل نسبة؟
أيش القيمة اللي تضيفها للتاجر؟
لا، هي ليش ما آخذ نسبة؟ لأن هذا شغلي
أنا أيش نموذج العمل حقي؟
نموذج العمل حقي أني أنا جالس اليوم
قناة تسويق للمطاعم وتوصيل للأكل حقهم، تمام؟
فيه مجهود، فيه شيء أعمله
من وين يجيني الربح؟
عمولة من المطاعم
النسبة ترى على فكرة، لما تتكلم على باقي الدول العالم
تزود عن 35% توصل لـ 40%
بدول الخليج أقل نسبة 25%
احنا هنا بـ«جاهز» وأنا يمكن قلتها يوم من الأيام
قلت: المفروض كل المطاعم
يحطون تمثال لـ«جاهز» في كل فرع من فروعهم
لأن احنا «جاهز» هي اللي حافظت على نسب منخفضة للمطاعم
من اليوم الأول، ولازالت إلى درجة
أن بعض التطبيقات الأخرى بدأت ترجع بالنسبة
تنزل نزول ما استمرت بالارتفاع
لأن في موجود منافس قوي مثل «جاهز» ونسبته أقل
هذا هو نموذج العمل حقي
بس بالأخير كم ماخذ؟
ما أجي آخذ ربح المطعم كله
لا بد آخذ اللي يربحني ويكفيني ويخليني أقوى
ويخليني أتطور ويخليني أسوّق
لكن برضه صاحب المهنة الأصلي
التاجر هو صاحب المشروع الأصلي وليس أنا، أنا وسيط
إذا ما يربح؛ ما راح يستمر
معناته أنا ما راح أستمر
فأنت تأخذ نسبة باختصار للتسويق وللتوصيل
هذولي أكبر قيمتين
هي اللي يحتاجها فعليًّا المطعم عشان يوصل للزبائن
صحيح
بس ليش نسبة مفتوحة؟
يعني ما هي مثلًا نسبة تقول
أنا باخذ 15% إلى 50 ريال مثلًا
أو 15% إلى 100 ريال
أيش العوامل اللي تقول لا، أنا أحتاجها تكون مفتوحة
ومتى ما كبر الطلب؛ تكبر النسبة معه؟
هذا كله ممكن يناقش
هي بالأخير أنا أقدم خدمة لك، زين؟
الخدمة هذه علشان أقدر أستمر بالخدمة
أبغى مقابلها مبلغ مالي
علشان أقدر أربح وأقدر أتوسع وأقدر أسوّق
وأقدر أكمل شغلي كامل
شلون تجي هذه؟
طريقة نسبة
فيه بعض التطبيقات الجديدة جات وقالت
أنا ما آخذ نسبة، آخذ على العميل
يعني بغض النظر عن المسميات
اليوم أنا بقدم لك خدمة
أنا مشروعي؛ باخذ منك مبلغ
عشان أستمر وأقدر أربح في نفس الوقت
المبلغ هذا إذا وصل كما قلت لك
إلى حصة كبيرة من ربحك
أنت كتاجر بديت تتضايق؛ تقول ما أبغى
نفس الشيء نرجع لعمارتك اللي على طريق الملك فهد
فاتح عمارة على طريق الملك فهد، مأجّر
إذا والله إيجارك هذا يبصير
يمثّل 50% من دخل صاحب المتجر
بغض النظر أيش المتجر
بيطلع منك، بيروح على طريق الملك عبدالله
بيروح على عمارة ثانية بطريق الملك فهد
فهو يبي ياخذ
ما عنده مانع يدفع لك قيمة الإيجار
والمبنى اللي جالس تقدمها له، والخدمة تقدمها له
بس بشرط تكون معقولة، نسبة وتناسب من مجمل أرباحك
فأنت ترى أن النسبة وصلوا الآن التجار إلى فهم لقيمتها
يقولون: أنا فاهم فعليًّا أن هذه القيمة
قاعد آخذها من جاهز؛ فهذه مستحقة
طبعًا، والدليل الحين استمرار الخدمة هذه وكمالها
والدليل أننا اليوم رفعنا يمكن إلى 13%
وشرحنا للمطاعم
وكلهم تقريبًا اقتنعوا
أننا ليش زدنا 1% من %12 إلى 13%
كان شرحي لهم حرفيًّا وبقوله لك الآن
أن اليوم احنا كشركة مطالبين بزيادة الأرباح
عندنا مستثمرين، والمستثمرين يبغون وين توسيع أرباحنا؟
من وين تجي مداخيلنا؟
فكان يضغطون علينا المستثمرين
يقول لك: ليش أنتم يا «جاهز» أقل نسبة بالعالم؟
هل هو قصور فيكم؟ هل أنتم أقل من غيركم؟
نقول لهم لا
ويدرون أنه لا، أننا أفضل
طيب ليش تاخذون أقل نسبة بالعالم؟
فلو نقبل ضغطهم ممكن نرتفع إلى نسب توافق
أو تساوي نسب باقي التطبيقات
صح
لكن نرجع على ثقافتنا اللي احنا نقولها
أو اعتقادنا أن النسبة يجب أن تكون دائمًا مرضية
دائمًا تارك مساحة ربحية كبيرة للمطاعم
عشان كذا تجينا مثل *التوافق
بيننا وبين المستثمرين والمطاعم
قلنا خل نزيد 1% نرضي مستثمرينا
رفعناها شوي، ولكن ما نأثر كثير على المطاعم
كان المستثمرين يطلبوننا نرتفع أكثر من هذا بكثير
والمطاعم ودهم ننزل
فجينا على هالمعادلة اللي تقريبًا أرضت الجهتين
المستثمرين والمطاعم
تمام، فهذا في الوضع الطبيعي
أنت عندك 13% تخدم المطعم مقابل تسويق وتوصيل
بس في الواقع فيه مطاعم، خاصةً المطاعم الغير معروفة
يعني المطاعم تحاول...
خلنا نقول في السنة الأولى أو السنة الثانية لها
فيه تكاليف إضافية عليها
فيه تكاليف أنه لازم يطلّع نفسه في الواجهة في «جاهز»
ما راح يجيه التسويق بشكل تلقائي
فيه تكاليف ممكن الانضمام لـ «جاهز برايم»
لأن هذا بندخل في فقرة خاصة فيه
بيصير يدفع أكثر على الطلبات
لأنه يحتاج يدخل توصيل مجاني
وإذا ما دخل توصيل مجاني
بيصير شكله هو الأغلى ما بين المطاعم الثانية
من ناحية تكلفة الطلب
ففيه تكاليف إضافية فوق النسبة
ما تشوف أن هذه قاعدة...
طبعًا لازم نكون منطقيين مع جميع الشغلات
أول شيء عندك صاحب مشروع
نتكلم الآن عن مطعم
عندك صاحب مطعم
عندك تكاليف وأسعار
وأنت تبيع وتبغى تربح
تشتغل بدون تسويق؛ بتخسر
أي مشروع: المطاعم نفسها تشتغل بدون تسويق؛ بتخسر
لكن تجي تشتغل وتحط ميزانية تسويقية كبيرة
أكبر من حجم مبيعاتك بكثير؛ بتخسر كمان
فوازنها
يعني اليوم مثلًا لو جينا على التسويق
مفروض تسوّق داخل التطبيق وخارج التطبيق
المفروض تسوّق
صح
لكن خلك متوازن
أنا أجي دائمًا لكثير من المطاعم وأقول له
والله لا تجي تبي تسوّق مثلًا
لما أتكلم عن أعلى القائمة
لا تجي تاخد أعلى القائمة لشهر كامل
أعلى القائمة اللي هو يطلع فوق
اللي هو يطلع فوق
لا تجي وتاخذ شهر كامل
ليه؟
خذ أيام متقطعة، يعني مرة ومرة
بحيث أنك تكون موجود، تسوّق
تصرف تسويقيًّا، لكن لا تصرف أكثر من اللازم
بعض أصحاب المطاعم...
خلني أعطيك مثال على أكبر مطعم هنا
مثلًا أكبر سلسة «ماكدونالدز» عمره ما أخذ تسويق شهر كامل
وهو أقوى مطعم بالمملكة  تسويقيًّا وقدرة وبيعيًّا
بس علامة تجارية معروفة
هذا ينصونه، ما يحتاج يطلع
لا، بس مع ذلك ما يجي يقول
والله أنا بسوّق طول السنة
عنده ميزانية ضخمة، بس ما يقول بسوّق طول السنة
ولا تلاقيه موجود بالخارج طول السنة
لازم تحسبها
يعني تخيل، ويمكن تسأل أصحاب المطاعم وبيقولوا لك
أنه نجلس مع أصحاب المطاعم
يبغى يصرف عندنا، نقول له: لا
ليش؟
لا تصرف، ما تحتاج. لا تخسر
بعض المطاعم يجي يقولك
أنا أبغى أحجز سنة كاملة
لا، لا تحجز سنة كاملة؛ غلط
بس مو أي ظهور بيفيده مفروض؟
أي تسويق طال عمرك، له حد معين وينتهي مفعوله
ما تجي تصرف ميزانية مفتوحة
عشان تقول: باخذ الدنيا، بكسّر الدنيا
بعض أصحاب وبالذات شباب الأعمال
الشباب في المطاعم نتكلم
فالشباب يجي يقول
باخذ السوق، أبغى أختصر السوق
بستولي على السوق، بطلّع منافسيني
كلام غير صحيح
تذكر بحياتك كاملة
كم منافس طلّع منافس من السوق؟
أنت الحين أسألك من يوم وعيت على الدنيا
وعرفت شيء اسمه تجارة لليوم
كم منافس شفت أنه طلّع منافس بسبب التسويق؟
ذاكرتي سيئة يا أبو عبدالله
ما راح تلقى، وإن لقيت واحد أو اثنين،
وتلاقي الأسباب؛ ماهو المنافس
أسباب داخلية بالشركة نفسها، تعبت وخسرت
بس مو منافس طلّعها
ما عرفت تواكب
إيه. يعني دخلنا على علامات تجارية
ارجع الحين بالذاكرة، ما أبغى أقول علامات تجارية
لكن ارجع بالذاكرة في مشروبات
أرجع بالذاكرة بالسيارات، ارجع الذاكرة بأي شيء
بتلاقي اثنينهم موجودين
ما يجي واحد أصرف أكثر؛ وبطلّع الثاني!
أنت كتاجر أحرص على شغلتين
أحرص أنك تتوسع وتربح بنفس الوقت
أتكلم عن التسويق بأي مكان
إذا وقفت تسويق؛ بتزوّد أرباحك للقطعة
لكن بتقل مبيعاتك بالجملة؛ فبتقل أرباحك الإجمالية
والعكس صحيح
لو والله ضربت بالتسويق وصرفت ميزانيات كبيرة
بتكبر مبيعاتك، ولكن بتخسر
فأنت تشوف فيه مشكلة في كفاءة التسويق عند التجار
ما أبي أقول كفاءة، لكن...
تعميم
هي ثقافات وهي خبرات تتراكم ويتعلمون الناس
كنا كلنا نتعلم
لكن هي بشكل عام أتكلم
وأتكلم عن أي مشروع تجاري
بالدين «لا أفراط ولا تفريط»
حلو
صح؟
صحيح
نفس الشيء بالمشروع التجاري
يجي واحد يقول أنا ما أبغى أسوّي أي مجهود تسويقي
ما راح يجيك شيء
ماسك كذا، ما راح يكبر
والثاني فاتحها بحري، ميزانية التسويق مفتوحة
خلك متعادل، اعرف وين
فنشوفها كتطبيق توصيل
إذا أنت بتستمر
أنا ما أتكلم بالتطبيق ترى، بأي شيء بما فيها التطبيقات
صحيح، بس في سياق التطبيق
أنت تشوف أن التاجر غير مجدي
أنه طول الوقت يسوّق؟
طبعًا
لأن الأثر يبدأ ينزل مع الوقت
غلط، مع أنه بيدفع لي فلوس
كيف تحاسبهم على فكرة على الإعلانات؟
هو الإعلان، سوى عاد أنه برأس القائمة
وللا إعلانات داخل التطبيق
كل إعلان له قيمة وعلى حسب المدينة
وحسب عدد الفروع لكل مطعم
فهو يختار الاستهداف، يختار أي مدينة يبغى يطلع فيها
أي منطقة ممكن صح؟
بالضبط
هل يبغى يطلع «بنر» فوق وللا؟
فيه «بنر» فيه إعلان منبثق
فيه أنه يصير برأس القائمة
اليوم صار عندنا خدمة جديدة بـ «جاهز»
جالسين نسويها مجانًا
لكنها تكون مدفوعة قريبًا
فيه خدمة اسمها «إكسبلور» ما أدري شفتها ولا للا؟
شفتها إيه
«إكسبلور» هذه على فكرة من اختراعات «جاهز»
على عالم التطبيقات على مستوى العالم
ما راح تلاقي «إكسبلور» بالطريقة هذه
بأي تطبيق في العالم
فـ«إكسبلور» هي صفحة خارج صفحة المطاعم
العميل اللي مستعجل بيطلب
يدخل لصفحة المطاعم ويطلب على كيفه
عميل رايق، روح لـ «إكسبلور»
بتشوف مطاعم عصرية، عناصر عصرية
تشوف أنواع كثيرة، تشوف بعض الأمور الثقافية
تشوف بعض الإحصائيات الخاصة فيك
تشوف أهم التغييرات في السوق
وخلالها بيكون هناك إعلانات برضه للمطعم
أيش المشكلة اللي تبغون تحلونها بـ«إكسبلور»؟
ما في مشكلة
نبي نزيد، نبي نخلي التطبيق أكثر عمق
نبي نصير أقرب من عملائنا
لأن احنا يوم من الأيام دخّلنا لعبة بالتطبيق
اليوم دخلنا «إكسبلور»
نبي نصير أكثر قرب من عملائنا
وأكثر عمق ونتطور
احنا من يوم بدينا الحمد لله
ما احنا جالسين ننقل أيش يسوون العالم
عشان نسوي مثلهم
من يوم بدينا
يعني فكرة التوزيع عن طريق طرف ثالث
من بدأها بالمنطقة «جاهز»
وكانوا كثير يراهنون أنها راح تفشل
والحمد لله الجميع الحقونا فيها
اليوم جالسين نطور شغلات كثيرة
هذه واحدة منها
حلو، أتذكر «هنقرستيشن» كان يخلي المطاعم هي اللي توصّل
مو بهو اللي...
إيه هذا النموذج اللي كان موجود أصلًا
بس هذا أنت ما حليت مشكلة على فكرة
لو ترجع للمطاعم
كانت تجربة سيئة مرة صراحة
لا، غير تجربة سيئة وكذا، لكن بقولك
أيش كان الوضع قبل؟
الوضع قبل فيه مطاعم معينة عندها أسطول توزيع
وباقي المطاعم وأغلبها ما عندها
المطاعم المقتدرة هي اللي عندها أسطول توزيع
حلو
فكانت توزّع عن طريق التلفون
أو عن طريق يدقون عليهم وياخذون الطلب كذا
جات التطبيقات اللي نزلت بذاك الوقت
صارت تخدم هذولا
أنه بدل ما يجيك تلفون
بيجيك الطلب من خلال التطبيق
أنا بعطيك التقنية اللازمة لإدارة الطلبات
بس، أني أجيب لك الطلب تقني، وأرسله لك وتكمل
طيب ما حلّيت المشكلة من ناحيتين
الـ 70% من المطاعم اللي ما عندهم أسطول التوزيع
ما استفادوا، هذا واحد
اثنين، ما كانت العملية متكاملة
يعني ما كانت لجميع الأطراف
التطبيق لما ياخذ الطلب
ما يتابع الطلب لما يروح للمندوب
ولما يوصل العميل
ياخذ الطلب ويرسله إلى المطعم
ووصّل عاد بطريقتك التقليدية
فالحل كان نفع مع من؟
نفع مع الشركات أو المطاعم اللي ما عندها أساطيل
أسلوبنا جاء، وصار لهم حل
أنه والله يقدر يوزّع بدون ما يتكلف بأسطول كبير
وبدأت العملية
وبعدين لحقونا كل التطبيقات
ودائمًا هذا أي واحد يجي جديد
أول سنة يضحكون عليه
يقولون: أيش عنده هذا؟
عنده نموذج ما راح ينجح، شوي ويمشي
بعد مرور سنة
كل التطبيقات اكتشفت أن هذا القرار الصحي
أو هذا الطريق الصحي؛ فقلدوها كلها
حلو أنا برجع للتكاليف حق المطعم
من ضمنها وبدايةً بموضوع التسويق
«إكسبلور» ما أتوقع تدفّع المطعم أكثر
إذا دخل المستخدم على...
لا «إكسبلور» ممكن أننا نستغني عن بعض الإعلانات
اللي حسينا أنها تضايق العملاء، والمطاعم يبغونها
مثلًا لما تفتح التطبيق الحين
تطلع لك إعلان منبثق
يا كثرها
الإعلان المنبثق مفيد لنا، فيه دخل مادي
مفيد للمطعم يعلن المطعم فيها. مزعج للعميل
الآن الإعلان المنبثق بنستغني عنه قريبًا
ويكون الإعلان داخل «إكسبلور»
موجود إعلانك ومستمر ما هو إعلان منبثق
يجلس لفترة معينة
فما يكون مزعج للعميل
العميل اللي فاضي؛ بيروح يتصفح ويروح يشوفه
العميل اللي مستعجل ولا يبغى أي شيء؛ يطلب ويمشي
«إكسبلور» لازم المطاعم تختار أنها تشارك معكم
وللا أنتم اللي تديرون كل شيء؟
لا، الإعلانات المدفوعة، هذه المطاعم تدخل فيها
بس المحتوى اللي موجود في...
لا، المحتوى بعضها يجي مشاركة من المطاعم
ونطلب منهم مشاركة، يعني اختياريًّا لهم
وبعضها من عندنا
وبعضها من الذكاء الاصطناعي عندنا
يعني الآن لما البيانات اللي عندنا ...
فالآن مثلًا أنت بيصير «إكسبلور» عندك يختلف عن واحد ثاني
أنت مثلًا بتجيك شغلات إذا أنك والله من محبين البرقر
بتجيك شغلات عن البرقر وما البرقر وكذا
وبتجيك الشغلات العصرية اللي تشابه لاختيارك
يعني النظام يعرف أنك والله غاوي برقر
فيبدأ يدف لك الأشياء البرقر الترند
وتطلب من مطاعم معينة
فلما يجي برقر جديد مثلًا عنده وجبة أنت تحبها
ممكن يطلعها لك، وترى هذه جديدة
لما يجي ترند بمجال معين ببعض المأكولات بتطلع لك
فهذه كلها تكون طالعة من البيانات اللي موجودة عندنا
تمام، فهذا حتى يمكن يساعد
لتسويق المطاعم برضه بشكل أفضل
بدل ما يصير على القائمة
فعندك النسبة قلنا حق المطعم
عنده الإعلانات يقدر يدفع عليها
الـ«برايم» يدفع كم تقريبًا على الطلب؟
فيه مبلغ ثابت؟
الـ «برايم» يتشارك في قيمة التوصيل المخفّضة
يصير هو يدفع جزء
نتشارك احنا وياه فيها
مبلغ ثابت؟
إيه
حلو، فـ«برايم» أيش هو؟
وفيه برضه التعويض للعملاء يكون على حساب المحلات صح؟
لا، التعويض ترى هذا يجي كلمات كثير
وتجي بتويتر ساعات، ويجي بعضهم يكتب بتويتر
أن والله «جاهز» بالاسم يقولها
جالسة تعوّض على حساب المطاعم
مش صحيح بالشكل هذا
متى تعوّض أنت على حساب المطاعم؟
اصبر خلنا بقولك شغلة
اسلم
واحد، «جاهز» من يوم بدأت كانت مؤمنة
أنه يجب أن نخدم العميل بطريقة لا يتوقعها
وفعلًا أعتقد ولازلت أعتقد
وأقولها وقلتها أكثر من مرة
أن «جاهز» عملت فرق بخدمة العملاء في المملكة
يمكن فيه مثال قلته أكثر من مرة
وقت من الأوقات طبعًا
خلها عشان ما أغفل غيرها
«جاهز» سوّت، بس برضه فيه تطور حكومي
ورقابة حكومية والوزرات تشتغل وكل شيء
بس وقت من الأوقات أتكلم على العميل
لو صار عندك مشكلة، مكينة السيارة أنت مشتريها
يمكن تتردد تروح تشتكي وللا لا
لأنك ما تدري يعوضونك وللا لا
الوكالة قصدك
الوكالة
في «جاهز» وصلنا وهذه حقيقة وليست كلام
أن عميل يتصل ويشتكي
لأنه المزاز ما وصل مع المشروب
ويجيه تعويض
ففكرة «جاهز» أني بعوّض العملاء، وهذا واحد
وبصير كريم بتعويض العملاء
طيب لما تعوّض العملاء بتكون بين نارين
طيب فيه ناس، وهو بكل مكان موجودين
فيه ناس يستغلون هذا الكرم الزايد
فإذا أنك تتساهل بالتعويض
راح يجون الناس يستغلونه
صح، راح يجون الناس يستغلونه
وهذا تزعج المطاعم، واحنا معهم، لأنه صح
لكن كيف أضبط هذه المعادلة؟
أني والله أعوّض المستحق بشكل كبير وسريع وسهل؟
وبنفس الوقت ما أؤثر أو ما أخلي مساحة كبيرة
خلني أقول للمستغلين، أنهم يستغلون هذه التعويضات
فيجي هنا برضه الذكاء الاصطناعي
أن اليوم أنت طلبت وطلبت تعويض
على طول قدام الوكيل اللي بيقابلك
مسؤول خدمة العملاء اللي عندنا
شايف ملفك على طول
والله طلباتك كلها كويسة وهنا فيه تعويض
أنت صادق، خلاص أمشّيك
ولا أحقق ولا شيء
أنت والله آخر أربع طلبات كلها طالب فيها تعويض
فيه علامة استفهام عليك
توصل، يمكن ما ينتبهوا لها الناس
توصل أن فيه تدرج
عميل واضح أنه كويس؛ الممثل يخدمه على طول
شوية متعب؛ يحوّله للمشرف
شوية كثير طلبات، نروح نطلب منه بريده الإلكتروني
لأن بريده الإلكتروني أول شيء مصعب العملية عليه
وبعدين نبغى نحقق أكثر فيه
حلو
وصلنا مرحلة أنك والله يا مشهور
عميل غير صادق، غير أمين معنا
سوينا لك حظر وقفلنا حسابك
أخسرك أزين لي
هذه المعادلة بشكل كامل
نجي على المطاعم
التعويض مو كله من المطاعم
التعويض احنا «جاهز» العام الماضي
أكثر من 40 مليون قيمة المصروف من «جاهز» على التعويضات
ورقم مهول ترى لما تسمعه بأي مكان بالعالم
أنه شركة تدفع 40 مليون تعويضات!
مبلغ كبير
هذا دفعته «جاهز» من ميزانية «جاهز»
فهي تعويضات على ثلاث شغلات
إذا والله المشكلة من المطعم 100%
وغالبًا تكون مشاكل المطاعم والله عنصر مفقود
طالب سبعة برقر وصل ستة
هو مو تعويض
هو تعويض للعميل أعطيه حقه
لكن المطعم ترى أنت دفعت قيمة اللي ما وصلته
أنت استلمت 100 ريال لعشرة برقر، ووصلت ثمانية برقر
فيجي بعوّض العميل بعشرين ريال وباخذها منك
أنت بالحقيقة خذيت الـ 100 حقت العشرة
ورجعت العشرين اللي أنت ما وصلتها بس، فهمتي علي؟
فهذه هي جزء منها
وطبعًا دائم نحرص بشيء ثاني
أن هذا التعويض ما يزود بأي حال من الأحوال
على مطعم بـ 2%
2%؟
إيه، وغالبًا أغلب المطاعم تقريبًا
يعني بالأحرى 1% الزيادة والنقصان شيء بسيط 1%
ودائم نقول للمطاعم، احنا نقولهم يوم كنا 12% نسبتنا
نقول ترى احنا معتبرين نسبتنا للمطاعم 14%
12% لنا 2% لعملائنا
هذه التعويضات
فلو جات التعويضات عليك 1% ترى كسبان 1% تاخذها
بس أنت قلت تحاسبه عن النقص
وأيش السيناريو الثاني؟
غالبًا النقص، هذا أكثر شيء
اثنين، والله إذا تأخر الطلب بشكل كبير
لو جيبنا مثال تأخير الطلب
إذا تأخر الطلب بشكل كبير، لها ثلاث حالات
إذا الطلب تأخر بالمطعم عن الوقت المتفق لتجهيز الأكلة هذه
اللي هو كم؟
على حسب تخصيص المطاعم
بس تقريبًا المتوسط 20 دقيقة
لأن بعض المطاعم تحتاج وقت أكثر
فإذا قلنا 20 دقيقة
وأنت سلّمت الأكل بعد نص ساعة
ووصل للعميل واشتكى
معناته مين متسبب؟ المطعم
فهو يتحمل المسئولية
حالة ثانية، أنت سلمت المطعم بالوقت
والمندوب راح لف ووصّل طلب ثاني
تعرف القصص هذه كلها، وصل العميل متأخر
المندوب بيتحمل
التعويض الحالة الثالثة
قصدك «جاهز» تتحمل التعويض
المندوب
المندوب نفسه
المندوب نفسه، إذا المندوب تأخر بالتوصيل
استلم بالوقت المناسب، وتأخر لما وصله للعميل
بدون سبب منطقي، ما كانت زحمة وللا إشارة مقفلة أو شيء
لا هو راح ووصل طلب ثاني أو أي شيء
المندوب يتحمله
في الحالة الثالثة، أنه والله وصل الطلب
و«جاهز» تأخرت بإسناد الطلب إلى مندوب
كان في نقص بالمناديب
فما وصل مندوب
ما أسند الطلب إلى مندوب إلا بعد وقت
وتأخر تسليم الطلب
هذا «جاهز» تتحمل التعويض
فلها تفاصيل كثيرة
بس أيش سبب زعل بعض المطاعم
هل هذا مشكلة التواصل، أو مشكلة التوقعات
أيش اللي صاير؟
لا، بعض المطاعم معهم حق
بس أنا لما أشرح لهم يعرفونها
مطعم يجي يلاقي حالة معينة
أن فيه عميل اشتكى والعميل غير صادق، وأخذ تعويض
فيجون يسوون اختبار مثلًا بعض المطاعم
يجون يسوونها يعني يوروني أيش صار
لا، يسوونها بعدين يجوني
يجي يطلب هو من مطعمه عشرة برقر مثلًا، زين؟
ويوصل الطلب عشرة برقر
ويشتكي عند «جاهز» يقول وصلني سبعة
ونعوضه
فيقول: هو هذا كاذب، شلون عوضتوه على حسابي؟
منطقيًّا صح كلامه، بس لما تقيسها
أنا دائمًا أقول لهم الشغلة هذه
خلنا نتفق هل نبغى نخدم العملاء الصادقين أو لا
إذا قلنا نبغى نخدم العملاء الصادقين
وأعتقد أننا متفقين كلنا نبغى نخدم الصادقين
علشان أتأكد أنه هذه النسبة البسيطة
من العملاء غير الصادقين وغير أمناء
عشان ما يخدعوني ويخدعون المطعم
لازم أستثمر مبالغ أكثر من قيمة التعويضات عشرين مرة
لازم أول شيء أحط بكل مطعم كاميرات
على المحاسب وهو يعبي هذه
ومربوطة برقم الطلب
وأحط فريق موجود عند المطعم
على حساب المطعم خدمة عملاء
ما عاد حاجة حتى أوصل للدرجة دي
وأحط عندي وأزود عدد خدمة العملاء عندي
خمس مرات أضاعفهم
فبضطر أرفع العمولة على المطاعم
عشان أغطي تكلفتي عشان اكتشف هذولا
مو بعملي أبدًا
أبدًا. احنا أيش نسوي؟
فكرتنا وهذا اختراعنا برضه
نقول: افترض الجميع صادق
أنت اليوم لو تجربها وتطلب تقول ناقص؛ بيجيك التعويض
لكن تقدر تخدعني مرة، ويمكن تخدعني مرتين
بس ما تقدر تخدعني ثلاث مرات
والخامسة بقفل حسابك وأوديك لتطبيق آخر
وفي جميع الأحوال محكومة في الـ 2% هذه
وكلها دائمًا نقيس
لا، الـ 2% هي مثل مقياس «كيه بي آي»
دائمًا نقيسها
من الحالات النادرة أنك تلقى التعويضات صارت أكثر من 2%
وإذا لقيناها
ودائمًا نقول للمطاعم إذا عندهم فروع كثيرة
بتلاقي فرعين ثلاثة عندهم مشاكل
فيها يعني عدم انضباط
فبتلاقي التعويضات قليلة، قليلة، قليلة؛ مرتفعة هناك
فهنا طوّر بعملياتك عشان تنقص
حلو، نرجع للنقطة الأساسية بس
عندك النسبة حق الطلبات فيه الـ«برايم»
فيه التعويضات إذا كان خطأ من المطعم
هذا الشيء أدّى للمطاعم كثيرة
أنها ترفع أسعارها في القائمة
لأنه يقول: أنا قاعد يطير علي النسبة هذه
بحق أو بدون حق
لا، أول شيء ترى قصة رفع الأسعار ما هي شيء كبير
وأغلب المطاعم أسعارها ثابتة
ورفع الأسعار ما لها علاقة بهذه
لها علاقات بأمور كثيرة
بعضهم ما يقدر يرفع بشكل عام؛ فيرفع جزئية
بس ما هي ترى قاعدة عامة
القاعدة العامة 90% من المطاعم أسعارها هي نفسها
بعض الأسئلة إذا جيت تسألني إياها الآن
نتائج تغريدات بتويتر لسبعة أو ثمانية أشخاص
أقدر أقولهم لك بالاسم الآن
هم اللي جالسين...
محرضين
مو محرضين، كل واحد له أسبابه
بس أنها تصير يا أبو عبدلله، يعني ما هي...
تصير، بس تتكلم على جزئيات بسيطة
لما تشوف تغريدات الستة أو السبعة أشخاص
إذا عندنا الوقت أقولها لك أساميهم
تحس وكأنه هذه العملية، وكأن المطاعم خسرانة
وكأن العملاء تعبانين، وكأن الدنيا سوداء
خذ الجانب الآخر
غمض شوي، تخيل اليوم ما في تطبيقات توصيل
تخيل أنك عميل
شوف أيش الفرق اللي بحياتك بيصير
ترى فيه جودة حياة كبيرة صارت
فيه تغيّر كبير صار حتى بأسلوب حياتنا
حتى لو تكون شباب بإستراحة
إذا تتذكر إذا كنت بإستراحة يوم الأيام
الهم لما مين يجيب العشاء
وتخرب الليلة وتخرب الجلسة
وإذا جالسين تلعبون بلوت؛ خرب البلوت
وقف البلوت لما يرجعون
لما يجي اللي راح يوصّل الأكل ويجيبه
تغيّر الأسلوب كثير
تخيل أنه والله بنات جالسين في البيت متجمعين
ويبغون أكل ساعتهم
لا القيمة معك يا أبو عبدالله
أنا أقولك هذه وين؟ للزبائن
خلنا نروح للمطاعم، من بعض المطاعم
التطبيقات المجرمين، في ناس يقولونها بتويتر
السبعة هذولا وبعضهم متأثرين في السبعة
تخيل أنك صاحب مطعم وما في تطبيقات توصيل
وعندك واحدة من حالتين
يا عندك أسطول، يا ما عندك
إذا ما عندك أسطول؛ كم واحد يبي يأخذ منك؟
كم تبي تبيع بعد الساعة عشر بالليل؟
اليوم أغلب المطاعم تشغل 24 ساعة
كم نسبة بيعك؟
كأنكم سويتوا خدمة تتيح لهم يستخدمون مناديبهم؟
إيه
حلو ، هذه كيف كانت؟
أقولك عليها الحين
إذا عندك أسطول كم التكلفة اللي بيكلفك؟ كم التعب؟
ونسبة العمالة ومشاكل العمالة وصيانة السيارات؟
ترى ارتحت من الموال هذا كله
بس طبعًا دائمًا الناس...
يعني أنا أقولك بعض الأصوات العالية
تخلي الصورة كأنها ماهي واضحة
التطبيقات على مستوى العالم عاملة فرق كبير
بالنسبة أرجع سؤالك إلى..
أساطيل المطاعم أتحنا لهم بالصدفة
شلون؟
احنا ما عندنا مانع، بالعكس احنا نبغى
نحتاج مندوبين أكثر وأكثر
واكتشفنا بالصدفة أن عندهم أساطيل
ويتوقعون أننا نرفض أن نتعامل معهم
وهذه الأساطيل جالسة تخسرهم
تشتغل عن طريقهم
بتغريدة واحد بتويتر
كتب تغريدة على المطاعم مثل العادة كذا
فواحد قال له: طيب ليش ما يستخدمون سواقينهم مع التطبيقات؟
رد عليه: التطبيقات ترفض
دخلت عليها أنا بتويتر بالخاص
قلت: أبد الله يحييكم، عندكم سواقين خلهم يجون
أنه يوصل طلباته هو بس؟
هو وللا يوصّل للجميع
قلت: الله يحييكم
تبغى تدخّل أسطولكم؟ تفضلوا معنا
قال: هذا عرض لي وللا للجميع
قلت: للجميع
قال: أعلن لك؟ قلت: أعلن
حلو
كتبها إعلان
أجيب سواقيني كمطعم وأخليهم يوصلون طلباتي فقط؟
تبغى توصل طلباتك فقط، أو تبغى توصل حتى طلبات غيرك
باستخدام تطبيق «جاهز»
وأنا كمطعم أكسب شيء لو وصلت طلبات غيري؟
طبعًا
احنا ترى قيمة التوصيل مو لنا يا التطبيقات
وهذه كثير ما يعرفونها
قيمة التوصيل هي للموصّل
هذه بندخل في تفاصيل المناديب
سواءً فرد أو شركة
فالشركة هذه أو المطعم اللي عنده مناديب
ممكن يوصل ويأخذ قيمة التوصيل
وتقل النسبة عليه؟
لا، مالها علاقة الآن
هذه النسبة هناك، الخدمة هذه قيمة التوصيل
فبدل ما يجي مندوب من برّا، يجي مندوبه
فخلنا نقول النسبة بتاخدون مثلًا 12%
اللي هي تاخذونها من المطاعم عادةً
بس أنه يقدر يسترجع جزء من قيمة التوصيل
إذا كان يستخدم مناديبه
وممكن يطلع بفائدة أكبر
معقولة؟
إيه، لأن الآن فيه شركات تشتغل هي شركات *«ثري بيل»
شغلها مربحها من التوصيل
شركات توصيل يعني
شركات توصيل
فهو الآن صار يشتغل شركة توصيل مع شغله كمطعم
فلما يطلع له ثلاثة عشر أو أربعة عشر ريال على الطلب
يمكن الطلب نفسه حقه ما يطلع ...
وما يفرق عنده مندوب وللا عشرة وللا عشرين؟
ما يفرق، بالنسبة لنا ما يفرق
بس طبعًا يفرق شغلة وحدة
أني اسمح لك توصّل طلباتك
هذا لأي مطعم
اسمح لك توصّل طلبات الغير
إذا صار عندك الشروط الكافية من هيئة النقل
أنها سامحة لك أنك تشتغل توصيل
لازم تاخذ موافقة
بنتكلم عن التوصيل بشكل مفصّل
بس فيه جزئية ما جاوبتني عليها، اللي هو السعر
من يتحكم فيه؟ هل لكم أي دور فيه؟
شلون؟
سعر الوجبة
خلنا نقول النسبة الصغيرة من المطاعم مثل ما تقول
رفعت أسعارها
ما نقدر، احنا ما نتغير
هو السعر يجي من المطعم، احنا ما لنا علاقة
فالمطعم هو اللي يدخّل السعر؟
إيه طبعًا احنا مالنا علاقة بالسعر
طبعًا فيه بعض ...
بس هل تقول له لا ترفع؟
وللا تقول له حط السعر اللي تبيه؟
احنا ما نبغاه يرفع، بس ما نقدر نجبره
لكن فيه بعض الناس يجي يقول لك
والله التطبيقات ترفع السعر، وتأخذ فائدة مضاعفة
ما أدري شلون يتوقعون أنه يتغيّر السعر ولمصلحتنا
مو صحيح
احنا السعر اللي يوضع من المطعم هو اللي نقبله
ومالنا علاقة بالموضوع
بس هي نسبة قليلة ترى رافعة الأسعار
بس دائمًا الصوت العالي يجي...
للسبعة الله يهديهم
للسبعة
بس باقي...
وأغلب السبعة على فكرة حبايب
وأتواصل معهم أنا
والله صدق وأعرفهم بالاسم وأتواصل معهم
بس أنهم يحبون...
طيب وراء غيركم لاقين...
مو بغيركم خلنا نتكلم بصريحة العبارة
«هنقرستيشن» لاقين سوق للـ 20%
ومطاعم كثير داخلين معهم بـ 20%
أيش اللي يخليكم تتمسكون بالنسبة حقكم هذه؟
نفس النقطة كنت أقولها لك
ترى على فكرة مو هنا، بالخليج نفس سياستنا
بالخليج احنا ناخذ 15% بالبحرين مثلًا
أقرب منافس لنا أقل نسبة عنده 22% واحنا  15%
نقدر نروح 20% هنا بالسعودية
نقدر نروح ما أحد يمنعنا
منافسنا أعلى منا ومنافسيننا أعلى مننا بكثير
تطبيقات أقل من «جاهز» كعدد وحجم؛ ونسبهم أعلى
الفكرة أن احنا نرى
أن النسبة يجب أن تكون عادلة للطرفين
مفيدة لنا ولا هي مخسرة للمطاعم
بحيث المطعم يقدر يكبر ويتوسع ويزود
أمّا أني بحاول أعصره؟ لا
لكن نقدر نعصر
لأنه كلما قلّت النسبة
كلما الأسعار كانت منطقية
والمطعم بدأ يحط وجبات أكثر
وصار عنده مساحة أنه يكبر
ويسوّق
ينمو، يزود
لكن والله تخيل أشتغل معك وأنا مخلي لك 1% ربح
بتكون طول عمرك تقول متى أتركه
أنا أتذكر فيه قصة
زمان وأنا صغير، شفت خبر استغربت
أن دول «أوبك» حاطه نطاق سعري
ما يقل عن كذا، وما يزود عن كذا
فكنت أفكر بوقتها بعقليتي البسيطة
طيب ما يقل عن كذا تمام، عشان ما نخسر
لكن ما يزود عن كذا ليش؟
هذا سعر البترول
للبترول إيه، ما يزود عن كذا ليش؟
ما كنت أقدر أتصور وأفهمها
أتذكر كانت يمكن خمسة وأربعين دولار، أو شيء مثل كذا
طيب ليش ما يروح خمسين، ستين، سبعين، مئة، مئتين؟
ليش يقول ما يبغى يزيد؟
فهمتها بعدين بعد ما كبرت
فنفس الشيء
أنا ما أبغى أزيد ربحي بشكل بحيث أني أوصّل لمطعم
أن والله أنا خسران مع التطبيق
خل أدوّر لي خيار آخر
تحتاج توزنها بحيث تضمن أن المطعم بيستمر معك
تزيد طلباته ويستثمر في تسويقه
صحيح
وكل هذه الأمور تكمّل
خدمة الحجز اللي عندكم اللي ضفتوها
برضه نفس النسبة تاخذون؟
لا، أقل
لأن ما في عاد توصيل هنا
لا أقل، لأن هذيك فيه خدمة توصيل وفيه خدمة غيره
أقل الحجز كم تكون تقريبًا؟
والله أعتقد 5%
منطقي يعني حجز الطاولات
ما شغّلتوا إلى الآن موضوع
أو فعّلتوا خاصية الاستلام من الفرع، أيش السالفة؟
قريبًا
حلو ياليت
تدري أنا أيش بسوي الحين؟
أنا أطلب أحيانًا إذا مستعجل وأروحه أستلمه
وأقول للمندوب يعطيك العافية
ما يحتاج، خاصة إذا التوصيل المجاني
لا لا قريبًا بتصير إن شاء الله
أيش اللي سبب تأخركم في الموضوع ذا؟
والله ما في سبب واضح
بس دائمًا أقولها
حتى أقولها داخليًا عند الزملاء
بعض المرات، بعض المدراء أقسام عندنا وللا شيء
يكون طالب له شغلة ويقول ليش؟
ليش ما تركّز على هذه؟
أبغى هذه تخلص بسرعة وللا كذا؟
بـ«جاهز» ترى مع أن الآن من يوم بدينا
وأنت تسأل على تطبيق التوصيل في «جاهز»
وهو جزء بسيط من شركة «جاهز»
جايكم عليه
ما يخالف
بـ«جاهز» فيه خدمات كثيرة
فما تقدر تنسى كل شيء
اليوم الطلب أو خدمة تطبيق «بِك» بتكون قريبًا نازلة
حجوزات طلعت
«إكسبلور» اللي أقولك الآن طلعت
خدمة المحفظة، المحفظة طورناها بشكل كبير
اليوم أنت قدر تحط فيها فلوس
وتحوّل من محفظتك لمحافظ ثانية
وتصير فيها شغلة
أن والله اليوم، وحدة من اللي يزعل المطاعم
يقول: أنت الآن تاخذ تعويض مني
والعميل يروح يطلب من أي مطعم
فكانوا طالبين، والآن تبي تصير
وأعتقد إذا نشر الحلقة هذه بيكون بعد أكثر من أسبوع
فهي بتكون صارت أصلًا قبل لا تنشر الحلقة
أنه خلاص أنت خذيت التعويض من مطعم «إكس»
بتستفيد من التعويض هذا في مطعم «إكس»
استرداد المبلغ نفس الشيء؟
لا، إذا كان فيه استرداد المبلغ من المطعم نفسه
بتكون فيه خدمات
لكن اليوم فيه شغلات داخل تطبيق «جاهز» للجميع
استرداد المبلغ داخل «جاهز»
هو داخل «جاهز» للجميع
لكن تعويض، عوّضك مطعم «إكس»
التعويض هذا تصرفه فقط في مطعم «إكس»
عوّضك «جاهز» تصرف في أي مكان في «جاهز»
التحويل بين المحافظ والأمور هذه
تحتاج تصريح من البنك المركزي وللا؟
لا، التحويل بين المحافظ عادي
لأنها هي ماهي حلقة مغلقة، ما تقدر تصرّفها بعدين
ما تقدر تصرّفها برّا «جاهز» مثلًا؟
لا، يدخل المبلغ هذا وينصرف في «جاهز»
فهذه حلقة مغلقة
خدمات مع الاتصالات السعودية
الـ *burning للقطاف خلال الأيام إن شاء الله بتشتغل
إعادة شحن
قاعدة تصب...
لا، الحمد لله
إعادة شحن، وتقدر تشحن بطاقات «سوا»
وللا بطاقات «موبايلي» عن طريق «جاهز»
كثير من الشغلات الحمد لله اللي بدأت تنزل
جميل، أنا بدخل على مواضيع كثيرة
لها علاقة في الأمور اللي ذكرتها
بس ودي أختم نقطة النسبة
بس معلومة مهمة أن النسبة اللي أذكرها
بخصوص سواءً «هنقرستيشن»
أو أي تطبيق ثاني خلال اللقاء هذا
نسبة كمثال فقط، والنسب طبعًا تختلف
سواءً في «هنقرستيشن» أو في «مرسول» أو غيرها
بتكون نسب مختلفة حسب المطعم وحسب اتفاقياتهم
فهذه أذكرها فقط كمثال وليس تثبيتًا للنسبة
عشان ما يزعل أحد من حقين التطبيقات هذه
ودي أدخل على الجانب التسويقي
ابتداءً في «جاهز برايم»
أيش اللي دعاكم لبداية «جاهز برايم»
اللي هو للي ما يعرفونه
«جاهز برايم» اشتراك، ادفع مبلغ ثابت شهري
واحصل على توصيل مجاني من المطاعم المشاركة
فأيش اللي خلاكم تبدأون «جاهز برايم»
والله هذا مو اختراع من عندنا
هذه خدمة «برايم» موجودة على مستوى العالم
يعني بأكثر من تطبيق
فهذه أنا قلتها قبل شوي
احنا نخترع شغلات كثيرة
لكن في شغلات برضه نقلّد فيها
فهي موجودة عند كثير من الخدمات خلني أقول على مستوى العالم
فمثلًا بـ«أمازون» موجودة
فطبّقنا مثلها
طبعًا هذا الجزء الأول منها
الجزء الثاني بيكون أكبر
الآن «برايم» أنت تستفيد فقط من أنه توصيل مجاني
قريبًا وهذه من ضمن الخدمات
بتستفيد من مزايا ثانية
أنه مثلًا لما تكون المدينة زحمة ومقفلة الخدمة
بتكون أنت مفتوحة لك الخدمة
لما نكون احنا ساعات في «جاهز»
نصغّر المسافات حسب الزحمة
حسب تواجد المندوبين
فساعات نصغر إلى ثلاثة كيلو
ونكبر إلى خمسة وعشرين كيلو
أنت «برايم» بتكون دائمًا خمسة وعشرين كيلو
ففيه كذا ميزة لعملاء «برايم» بتنزل الآن
أيش اللي يغيّر السعر دائمًا؟
أنا أذكر أول ما بديتوا الظاهر كان خمسة وتسعين
وبعدين خمسة وسبعين، يتغيّر
كل شهر أجي أجدّد أكتشف...
كل أسبوع
الظاهر يصير أجدد شهريًّا
أكتشف المبلغ مختلف، أيش اللي يغيّر في سعره؟
أكون صادق؟
جرّب
خل أعطيك بصراحة يمكن ما تصدقني فيها
سعر الـ «برايم» السعر العادل ما بين خمسة وسبعين وخمسة وتسعين
هو السعر العادل لـ«برايم»
بدأناها و هي خدمة لـ«برايم»
بين خمسة وسبعين وخمسة وتسعين
تكون مفيدة للعميل، لنا، للمطعم
أنتم كنتم مسعرينها على أساس
أن العميل على افتراض أن يدفع مقدمًا للخمس طلبات
هي خدمتها شلون؟
أو قيمة توصيل خمس طلبات مثلًا مقدمًا
تقريبًا، شغلة مثل كذا
إذ أنك عميل من أبو عشرة طلبات وأعلى
بتكون مفيدة لك لما تدفع خمسة وتسعين، حلو؟
أنا لما أحافظ عليك طول الشهر؛ بتكون مفيدة لي
المطعم يدفع مبلغ أقل
يكون برضه تجيه ميزة أن عملاء «برايم» يجونه أكثر
فهي مدروسة بهذه الطريقة، وهذه هي الصح
المطعم أيش يستفيد؟
المطعم قاعد يدفع زيادة على...
لا، بس أنه يسوّق
لأن عميل «برايم» بيأخذ منه، ما بياخذ من مطعم ثاني
لأن بياخذها مجاني هنا التوصيل
أنتم تشوفون فيه الحين
تحيز لعملاء «برايم» لمطاعم «برايم» أكثر من...
لا مو تحيز، لأنك أنت الآن لما تجي
وفيه ميزة هنا مجاني وهنا غير مجاني؛ فتفرق معك
أنا قصدي مسألة التوصيل المجاني
يخلي العميل مثلًا بدل ما يطلب المطعم
اللي يطلب منه عادةً
بس أنه ماهو مشارك في الـ«برايم»
يروح يدوّر...
يعني ماهي بهذه الطريقة
ماهي 100% بس تزيد نسبة أنه بيطلب من هناك
إذا كان خيار العميل نفس الشيء تقريبًا
مطعم «إيه» وللا مطعم «بي»
وهذا بدون سعر، بدون توصيل؛ بيروح لهذا
لكن أنا والله مشتهي «مثلوثة»
ما راح أروح لبرقر أو البيتزا عشانها بدون توصيل، فهمت علي؟
تقدر تشارك نسبة المطاعم اللي شاركت في «برايم»؟
إيه نسبة عالية
فوق 50%؟
لا، لا ما تصل لـ 50% لكن نسبة عالية، يمكن فوق 30%
فهذه الفكرة اللي تخدم جميع الأطراف
في النموذج هذا حق الاشتراكات
ممكن واحد يشترك معك مثلًا بخمسين، ستين، تسعين ريال
ولا يوصل عدد الطلبات اللي افترضت أنه بيطلبونها
فتتربّح منه شوي
إيه، هذا النموذج حقه أصلًا
الحين أنت لما تدخل وتأمّن على سيارتك
وتأمّن على نفسك وتأمّن على كذا
الفكرة هو الاقتصاد التشاركي
أمّنوا ألف واحد، زين؟
200 منهم استخدموا التأمين أكثر من قيمة تأمينهم
الـ800 الباقيين ما استخدموا، واستخدموا أقل
بالأخير، المؤمِّن مستفيد، والمؤمَّن عليه مستفيد
هذه فكرة المشروع
«برايم» نفس الشيء
دخلوا 50 ألف بـ«برايم» دفعوا خمسة وتسعين ريال
10 ألاف طلبوا ثلاثين طلب
فنظريًّا مخسريني لأنها صارت كلها مجانًا الثلاثين طلب
5 ألف طلبوا بحدود العشرة
فيكون الباقيين طلبوا سبعة أو ثمانية
هذا كمثال
كمثال، مكسبينني عشرة أو خمسة عشر ريال
بالمجمل أنا كسبان كشركة
وفوقها تضمن أنك تحافظ على العميل
ضامن العميل معي إيه
اللي اشترك كسبان، المطعم كسبان
ما أتصور بتكملون كذا
ممكن يصير التوجه أنه بتضيف مزايا أكثر
غير التوصيل المجاني، فتبدأ ترفع
هذا الصحيح، وهذه تشتغل فيه «جاهز» دائمًا
«جاهز» دائمًا تشتغل على رفع القيمة
رفع القيمة وليس المبلغ
فالحمد لله، ترى من يوم بدت «جاهز» وأسعارها أغلى
يعني عشان تكون طبيعي
دائمًا التصور عند العملاء أنها أغلى من غيرها
صح
أتذكر ببدايات «جاهز» سمعت كلمة بإستراحة
وقلت للزملاء أتذكر للأمير «مشعل» و«غصاب المنديل»
قلت: نجحنا يالربع، ترانا ناجحين
بإستراحة جالسين فيه واحد ما يعرفني
فيسألون ويتكلمون «جاهز»
وباقي التطبيقات بدون ما أسمّي
فقال واحد: والله أنا إذا جيعان أطلب من «جاهز»
لأني أضمن توصل بسرعة، ومضمون وصولها
إذا لا ما أنا جيعان؛ أدور من أرخص تطبيق وأطلب منه
فصار الثقة في «جاهز»
هذه الحمد لله، اللي موجودة إلى اليوم
إلى اليوم اللي يبغى الخدمة الأسرع الأفضل بيلاقيها بـ«جاهز»
بس ما تعتقد أنه كان...
يبغى أرخص؛ ممكن يلقاها المكان ثاني
إلى اليوم أقول لك: ممكن يلقاها مكان ثاني
ما تعتقد أن هذه كأنه تأثير مباشر
على حصتكم السوقية أنكم الثاني بدل الأول؟
من يقول أنه الثاني؟
هذه الأرقام اللي نعرفها
وينها؟ من وين جبتها؟
أنت تشوف أنك الأول اليوم؟
من وين جبتها؟
أنا أسألك، اليوم هل تشوف أنك الأول و للا لا؟
ما أقدر أصرح صراحة
بعض الأرقام ما أقدر أصرحها
إذا عندك أرقام أو إحصائيات؛ قلها
إذا فيه إحصائيات موثوقة؛ قلها
أو لو الناس تتكلم؛ كلام كثير
أنا ما أقدر أجيب لك شيء موثّق 100%
بس اللي أعرفه أن «هنقرستيشن» هو الأول
و«جاهز» هو الثاني
الثالث «مرسول» وبعدين التطبيقات الثانية
والله كلٍ يدعي، فيه تطبيق ما أدري يش اسمه
قبل قالوا هو 10% ما أدري كم
ما هو معروف، أتمنى أشوف واحد طلب منه
بس السؤال، أنتم الأول؟
فما فيه إحصائيات كبيرة
كعدد طلبات
لكن احنا بـ «جاهز» دائمًا عنواننا التطبيق الأول بالمملكة
احنا التطبيق الأول بالمملكة
بغض النظر عن عدد العملاء
اللي ما في أرقام موثوقة رسمية
أو لها مرجعية تثق فيها تطلع أرقام
احنا التطبيق الأول في المملكة
حلو، قبل ما نعدّي نقطة «برايم»
تقدر تصرّح عن عدد المشتركين وللا لا؟
تتغيّر يوم عن يوم، ما أقدر
يعني ما أعرف، اليوم بتقولي والله ما أدري كم
النطاق مثلًا؟
ما أدري، بس فيه رقم كبير
بعشرات الالاف أو أكثر؟
إيه، طبعًا
حلو، رعاية «الهلال» أيش الطاري؟
أيش اللي جاب لكم فكرة رعاية «الهلال»؟
رعاية «الهلال» من جهتين جايه
خل أجيب لك الحدث اللي صار وقتها، والسبب الرئيسي
السبب الرئيسي احنا بـ«جاهز»
احنا كأفراد يعني مؤسسين لـ«جاهز»
عندنا نظرة يمكن ما كان يشاركنا فيها الكثير وقتها
اليوم الجميع يشاركنا فيها
أن الاستثمار الرياضي شيء مهم جدًّا
وأن الرياضة صناعة وليست مضيعة وقت
والرياضة يعتمد عليها بالصناعة، بالسياحة
بأمور كثيرة، بالترفيه
يعني مؤمنين بالكلام هذا، وقتها مو كثير مثلنا
فتلاقي كثير من الشركات
لما يدخل يحس إنها مضيعة وقت
وللا مضيعة فلوس، ومضيعة وقت؛ لما يدخل برعايات
احنا لا، كنا مقتنعين بالمجال هذا
وحتى لنا كأفراد داخل «جاهز»
في ماضينا قبل «جاهز» بتلاقي لنا تاريخ بالرعايات كلنا
فمهتمين بالمجال الرياضي
السبب الرئيسي كان دخول رعاية «الهلال» وقتها
أنه صار فيه كما ما نتكلم الحين بحرب أسعار
كان فيه حرب أسعار شرسة جدًّا بين تطبيقين موجودة
وصلت لكسر عظم
واحنا خسرانين بالسوق، لأن احنا سعرنا ثابت
والناس هذولا خصومات
وتوصيل مجاني واسترداد المبلغ
يعني تلاقي تاخذ توصيل مجاني، واسترداد المبلغ 50%
وفوقها بوسة وما أدري شلون، بشكل خطير
فبدينا نخسر من حصتنا السوقية
واحنا توّنا بسنتنا الثانية تقريبًا
فكان قرار استراتيجي
هل ندخل بالحرب هذه مع الناس هذولا؟
وكان يعني...
حرب تسويقية؟
حرب أسعار شرسة جدًّا
كتوصيل وللا أيش؟
كل شيء، أسعار بكل شيء
خصم 50% استرداد مبلغ، توصيل مجاني، ما أدري شلون
حرب شرسة
حتى تسويقيًا وقتها كنتوا هادين، مو مثل الحين
إيه جدًّا، ولازلنا هادين
فكرنا جديًّا، فكرنا حتى ندخل بالحرب هذه
بس اللي منعنا منها شغلتين
وحدة، أنه ما نؤمن بالطريقة هذه
طريقة حرب الأسعار
طريقة طلّع منافسك
طريقة أحرق منافسك
ما نقتنع فيه، لا ذاك اليوم ولا اليوم
الثانية، أننا حتى لو اقتنعنا أننا ندخل بالحرب
وفكرنا فيها؛ ما نقدر
يحتاج لك على قولة الأجانب يحتاج لك مخبى مليان
لأنك بتحرق فلوس واجد
فالرعاية ما شاء الله احتاجت مخبى مليان
فوق الـ 100 مليون، صح؟
وين؟
رعاية «الهلال»
لا، بس وقتها أقل من لو صرفناها بحرق
الحرق كان واجد، حرق فلوس
كانت الموضة *احرق فلوس يعني بشكل
يعني أقل من *عاد تبدأ بتخفيضات واسترداد المبلغ والأمور دي كلها
بس مبالغ كبيرة
بهذه الأثناء واحنا بإعادة التفكير
جتنا زيارة من «الهلال» يعرضون رعاية
فكان هو المنقذ
طبعًا جات، لإيماننا كما ما قلت لك بالرياضة
كلنا هلاليين، والأجواء هذه اللي كانت بحرب الأسعار
فجاءت مناسبة جدًّا
دخلنا بدون تردد
واعتقد وأدّعي أننا كنا أذكياء بقوة ولازلنا
كانت الرعاية، وهذه برضه القصة بقولها لأول مرة يمكن
الرعاية معروضة علينا بالظهر وبمبلغ معين
مساحة كبيرة
قلنا: لا ما نبغى المساحة الكبيرة
وأحمر
لا، أحمر أحمر
بس لا، المساحة المعروضة لنا بالظهر
مساحة كبيرة وبسعر معين
قلنا ما نقدر ندفع المبلغ هذا
نبغى أقل وبالصدر
والله أنه أحسن من الظهر
مو أحسن، أنا أقول لك اليوم
أنا أدّعي أنها ذكاء كبير مننا وأهايط فيه
كل سلفي طالع فيه وأحمر كذا منوّر
اليوم شعاره، قلنا شعار صغير هنا
لكن اليوم لو تركّز تلاقي يمكن 90%
من صور اللعيبة اللي يطلعوا من «الهلال»
يطلع شعار «جاهز»
بالضبط
وغالب يطلع لوحده
يعني اليوم لو تقارنه بالإعلان الرئيسي يمكن يسوى أكثر
وهذا كان ذكاء من عندنا
وذكاء جاء من «الهلال» أنهم وافقوا على المساحة هذه
كانت فاضية ما فيها شيء
فوافقوا عليها، فكان مدخول إضافي لهم
بس بالنسبة لنا أعتقد أننا خذينا النقطة الأهم
المبلغ ليس كبير
رعايتنا لـ «الهلال» من أفيد الرعايات صراحة
أنا متأكد كعلامة تجارية استفدتوا كثير منها
استفدنا كثير بيعيًّا وكل شيء
شفتوا لها أثر كبير يبرر القيمة؟
جدًّا، والدليل يمكن هذه أنا ما أدري
إذا صارت بمكانٍ ما بالعالم وللا لا
لكن احنا هنا في السعودية
الشركة الوحيدة اللي تجدد رعايتها قبل لا تنتهي هي «جاهز»
ما أتذكر ولا أعرف على حسب معلوماتي
أن فيه شركة مددت الرعاية قبل نهايتها بسنة
احنا كان من المفترض ننتهي نهاية السنة هذه
احنا العام الماضي مددنا ثلاث سنوات
من كثر ما هي مجدية
من كثر ما هي مجدية، وبرضه خل أدّعي بشغلة ثانية
أننا شايفين المستقبل وقارين المستقبل اللي صاير اليوم
فعارفين أنه والله الدوري بيصير أقوى
المنافسات بيصير أقوى، الرعايات بتصير أغلى
فجددناها قبل
وتطبيق «بلو» هم مقترحينه وللا أنتم اللي طرحتوه
تطبيق «بلو» موضوع ثاني الحين، مو الرعاية
لكن هذيك الرعاية أتكلم
فبالمكان كانت مهمة
التجديد كان شيء جديد
بالعادة اللاعبين هم اللي يجددون لهم قبل سنتين
وللا لاعب عندك كويس، باقي له سنتين
مدد عقده أربع سنوات، وزيده شوية
علشان تضمنه معك
احنا بـ«جاهز» جددنا الرعاية
أنا لحد علمي إلى اليوم ما أعرف
هل فيه شركة بالعالم مددت الرعاية قبل تنتهي بسنة؟
ما أعرف، وهذا أعتقد أنه ذكاء برضه من «جاهز»
«بلو» يجي على هامش رعايتنا لـ«الهلال»
ما هو مرتبط فيها؟
لا، مرتبط فيها، هو على هامش الرعاية
أنت لما تسوي رعاية لنادي كبير مثل «الهلال»
وللا لأي مكان، تحتاج تفعيل
تفعيل للرعاية
إيه. الناس، الشركات يعني خلني أهايط شوي
وأزيد بكلمة أهايط قلتها مرتين
فيه شركات ترعى وبس تحط شعارها وخلاص
فيه شركات ترعى وتحط أنشطة وكذا
وتصير كويسة وكذا، ويسمون عملوا تفعيل كويس
احنا بـ«جاهز» سوينا الرعاية، وسوينا تفعيل
وصار فيه ارتباط مع الجماهير بشكل كبير الحمد الله
زودنا عليها، قفزنا من الرعاية للشراكة
فجينا اقترحنا على «الهلال»
طيب ليش ما نسوي تطبيق مشترك احنا وإياكم
وهو يرجع لنفس ثقافتنا بـ«جاهز»
لما نقول: الربح ربح
نعمل شغلة بتكسبكم كثير وبتكسبنا كثير
اثنيننا ربحانين
نعمل تطبيق مشترك، تقنيًا عندنا
*النوهاو عندنا
إدارة الحدث كاملة عندنا
أنتم عندكم الأسهم، عندكم المنتجات
فنطلع بشيء مهم
طلعنا «بلو» طبعًا كانت مفاوضاتنا
أو نقاشاتنا مع «الهلال» سلسة مرة
لأننا نتكلم مع ناس فاهمين
وعارفين مجال الرياضة وعارفين المشروع
كانت سلسة مرة هي
جدًّا بشكل أكبر مما تخيل
فطلعنا بـ «بلو»
«بلو» اليوم خلني أقولك بعد وأعطيك حصري
اليوم «بلو» يسوى أكثر من 500 مليون ترى
شلون قيمته؟
قيمته تسوى أكثر من 500 مليون
التقييمات الأولية طبعًا خلنا نقول
الحمدلله، صار له قيمة كبيرة
والملكية متشاركة بينكم وبينهم؟
احنا 51% لـ«جاهز» و 49% لـ«الهلال»
ليش 51% تحديدًا؟
صعب تصير 50% و 50%
فلازم فيه واحد
واحد اللي هو للمالك الأكثرية
وكان بيني وبينك يوم صارت 51%
من ضمن النقاشات، أن إدارات الأندية تتغير مع الوقت
قبل طبعًا القفزة الجديد اللي صارت الآن
فممكن تجي إدارة غير ملمة بالاستثمار وللا شيء
وتأثر على هذا المشروع فقلنا وقنعناهم
أنه والله احنا كشركة قائمة تجارية
احنا حافظة تجارية فأفضل أنها تصير 51%
فأقول لك: أنه طلعنا بلا شيء إلى مشروع مثل كذا
احنا بـ«جاهز» لو انتهى مشروعنا
مع «الهلال» فقط في «بلو»
كفانا تجاريًّا
ما شاء الله
بغض النظر عن أي مكسب آخر كسبناه طول الخمس سنوات
ما أتوقع كان مكلف أساسًا من ناحية...
لا، أبدًا
الخبرات موجودة عندكم
سواءً من ناحية بناء التطبيق أو من ناحية التوصيل
الخبرات موجودة، التقنية موجودة
بناء التقنية كله داخل «جاهز»
فما هي مكلفة
فلو ما ينطلع إلا بهذه؛ احنا كسبانيين
مع أننا كسبنا شغلات كثيرة
وهل تقسمون الإيرادات بينكم يعني؟
وللا تتشاركونها؟ وللا تعاملونها كأنها شركة مستقلة؟
لا، هي شركة مستقلة
هي تبع شركة مستقلة
شركة مستقلة اسمها «بلو»
يملك فيها الهلال 49% يملك فيها «جاهز» 51%
لها مدير ولها...
طبعًا إيه
طبعًا من ضمن واجبات «جاهز»
بناء الهيكل الإداري، والإشراف على إدارتها
لحد ما تكون مستقلة إداريًّا تمامًا
ارجع وأقولك الرعاية
احنا لو جينا بس لـ «بلو» كفانا مكسب
لو جينا على العائد المباشر
وغير المباشر من الرعاية لـ«جاهز» الحمد لله كسبنا
لو أخذت «الهلال» جيت على العائد المادي
100 مليون أول خمس سنوات
وبتكمل سنتين زيادة، لتوصل إلى 140 تقريبًا
أكثر من 140
زائد مكافآت فوز وكذا
بعض الدعم اللوجستي من «جاهز»
فمفيدة جدًّا لـ«الهلال»
وطلعوا في شركة يملكونها ولها قيمة
نتوقع إن شاء الله قيمتها بتدخل
عالم الشركات المليارية إن شاء الله وقريبًا
تسوى أكثر من مليار تصير
بإذن الله
فأنتم حتى عوائد التذاكر تشاركون فيها في الشركة هذه وللا؟
احنا نبيع التذاكر ولنا العمولة حق التطبيق
تاخذون عمولة منها؟
بس عمولة إيه
كم عدد الطلبات اللي وصلتوها بالمناسبة في تطبيق «بلو» حاليًا؟
باليوم؟ وللا بالسنة
وللا بالساعة
لا، عاد معليش
لا، تطبيق «بلو» عدد كبير الحمد لله
بس تطبيق «بلو» فيه ميزة كبيرة جدًّا الحمدلله
خل أربطه بشغلة ثانية كبيرة
اليوم لما أتكلم على الاستثمار الرياضي
لما أتكلم على جلب اللعيبة
من كل دول العالم ومبالغ ومليارات
ويجي لك بعض الناس والله جالسين
الحكومة تصرف مليارات على مبالغ
ترى هذه المليارات جالسة تصرف
قطاعات كثيرة تستفيد منها
السياحة تستفيد، أمور كثيرة تستفيد، الصناعة
احنا جالسين نستفيد
احنا اليوم في «جاهز» من خلال «بلو»
جالسين نستفيد من هذه الاستثمارات اللي صُرفت على اللعيبة
أعطيك رقم صادم
سبعة وثلاثين دولة شحنا لها شيرتات لـ«الهلال» من«بلو»
سبعة وثلاثين *سوفار
أسماء، عد واغلط
أنا ما كنت أدري أنكم تشحنون برّا السعودية أساسًا
إيه طبعًا
جاتنا طلبات من البرازيل، فنزويلا، كوريا الجنوبية
البوسنة، أمريكا، فرنسا، أسبانيا، وعد
لاحظ ترى جالسين نسجّل اليوم ما بدأ الدوري
ما بدأ الدوري لسه
بس يوم بدوا اللعيبة يجون
وجاوا مجموعة من لعيبة «الهلال»
اليوم احنا ما أدري كم التاريخ، ستة وللا كم؟
عندنا أربعة لعيبة جدد جايين للهلال فقط
لأنه ما راح تعرض اليوم الحلقة هذه
إن شاء الله يوم ما تعرض يصير واصلين ثمانية
بس ما أقول
عندك أخبار يعني؟
إن شاء الله نقول، فاليوم جالسين نبيع شيرتات
سواءً لـ«الهلال» بشكل عام أو شيرتات بأسامي اللعيبة هذولا
لسبعة وثلاثين دولة خارج المملكة
طلبات كمية معتبرة يعني وللا؟
إيه أرقام وكل مالها تزود
بس هل تقرر تفصح عن عدد الطلبات
في تطبيق «بلو» مثلًا في السنة هذه؟
ما أقدر أقول لك الرقم بالضبط
لأنه ما يحضرني صراحة
بس أنه جالس يزود الحمد لله بشكل كبير جدًّا
لكن أقول لك: أن استثمار «بلو» استثمار من أروع الاستثمارات
وهذا اللي خلاكم برضه ترعون النقل التلفزيوني الحين برضه
النقل التلفزيوني رعايتنا له نفس الفكرة
لما أقول لك أننا مؤمنين بصناعة الرياضة
مؤمنين فيها بشكل كبير
اليوم النقل التلفزيوني
طبعًا الـ«إس سي سي» هي آخذه حصريًّا على الميناء
في الشرق الأوسط وشمال أفريقيا
فاليوم أنا لما أرعى النقل التلفزيوني
بتطلع وفيه متابعة كبيرة بدول الخليج مثلًا
أنا اليوم «جاهز» موجود في البحرين، موجود في الكويت
فالإعلان اللي جالس أصرف عليه
في السعودية في الـ «إس سي سي»
بيشوفونه عملائي بالكويت، وعملائي في البحرين
وإن شاء الله قريبًا بكون بدول ثانية خليجية
فجالس أستفيد بشكل كبير
الزخم ترى اللي جالس يصير بالدوري بشكل ما تتخيله
بس يمكن مو كثير متخيلينه ومتخيلين أنه يستفيدون منه
احنا بـ«جاهز» مؤمنين
أن الحراك هذا مفيد للبلد بشكل كامل
مفيد للاقتصاد، مفيد للشركات، ونبغى نستفيد
وطمعانين نستفيد من هذا الحراك بأكبر قدر ممكن
حلو، هذه واضحة في حالة الكرة
بس ليش ترعى مثلًا الـ«فورميلا إي»
من جهتين: جهة أنه كما قلت لك
احنا مؤمنين أن الرياضة بشكل كامل
مركبة كبيرة جدًّا تسرّع توصيلك
أو وصول اسمك بأسرع طريقة ممكنة
أكثر من أي شيء ثاني
فمؤمنين بالرياضة بشكل كامل
أنها أسرع طريقة لتوصيل اسمك
والحمد لله، احنا «جاهز» ترى مالنا إلا خمس سنوات
فيه ناس يحسبون لنا خمسين سنة أو ستين سنة
لخمس أو ست سنوات
اسمنا صار أقوى من شركات عريقة جدًّا الحمد لله
برعايتنا لهذه الجهات
الجهة الأخرى، أننا برضه نعتبر نفسنا شركة وطنية
قريبًا إن شاء الله بنصير من ضمن الأبطال الوطنيين اللي بتصير
الشركات الوطنية العظيمة
الأبطال المحليين
الأبطال المحليين، هذه إن شاء الله فيه قطاع حكومي بيصير
أو دعم حكومي للشركات اللي مرشحة تصير من الأبطال المحليين
وإن شاء الله بنصير من ضمنها
احنا شركة وطنية لنا دور برضه أو علينا واجب
اليوم أنا من وين جبت فلوسي كشركة؟
من المملكة العربية السعودية
كل شغلي جايبه هنا
صح
لما أرجّع جزء منها على شكل تسويقي يفيدني تسويقيًّا
ويساعد في دعم أنشطة وحراك رياضي أو اجتماعي
أو حتى ثقافي
أنا معك بالفكرة، بس ليش «فورميلا إي»
من نفس هذا الحراك
احنا تلاقينا بـ«فورميلا إي»
وبنفس الوقت تقريبًا من ذاك الوقت مع مزايين الإبل
هذه لها جمهورها، هذه لها جمهورها
فأنتم داخلين في عدة نشاطات؟
إيه، احنا موجودين بالطائرة كنا، بالقولف، بالسلة
بالفورميلا، في المزاين، في الخيل
في أكثر الأنشطة
منها أثر وللا؟
طبعًا، اليوم لما أرجع وأقول لك
«جاهز» هي الأولى بالمملكة، ما جات من فراغ
جات من عمل كثير تقني
عمل كثير بالتشغيل، عمل كثير بالتسويق
جزء من هذا التسويق هي الرعايات
دائمًا أقولها للشركات
الدقة القديمة يقولك: لا تضيع فلوسك على شغلات كذا وكذا
خلّي أقولها لك بجهة ثانية
اترك أن احنا يالشركات السعودية والشركات الوطنية
واترك حتى الجانب الوطني فيها
هذه الشركات العالمية الضخمة
هل هم أغبياء وجالسين يضيعون فلوسهم؟
لا، طبعًا
شوف الفورمولا مين يرعاها؟
أعظم الشركات العالمية
صح
شوف الدوريات العالمية، مين يرعاها؟
شوف أعظم الشركات بالعالم
بتلاقيها راعية أكثر من نشاط رياضي
يعني أغبياء وللا وجالسين يضيعون فلوسهم؟
لا، صحيح
فهي هذه، ترى التسويق...
الرياضة، يمكن وقت من الأوقات كما قلت لك
بالمملكة عندنا هنا مو كثير ناس يتوقعون
أن هذه قاطرة مهمة للتسويق يستفد منها
يعتبرونها أما والله أنك تصير
يعني تبغى تدعم نادي وللا تدعم جهة
كدعم فتحط فيها فلوس
وللا روح دور غيرها
والله مسؤولين وزارة الرياضة ينبسطون على التصريح
لا، صحيح وأنا قلتها أكثر من مرة
قلتها وبكررها اليوم معك
احنا مثلًا مع «الهلال» كل ريال دفعناه؛ جانا عشرة
وعلى فكرة، الكلمة هذه قايلها قبل لا تصير في «جاهز»
قبل «جاهز» وأنا قايل نفس الكلام
بالرياضة كل ريال تدفعه؛ يرجع لك عشرة
اليوم مع الحراك الرياضي الكبير
والدعم الحكومي الغير مسبوق على مستوى العالم
كل ريال تدفعه بالرياضة؛ بيجيك مئة
واللي ما يدخل ويستفيد من هذا الحراك
بيفوته القطار
بيفوته القطار فعلًا
أنا أقولها للشركات بشكل عام وللمنافسين حتى لنا
إذا ما تدخل هذا المجال؛ تراك تفوته
ترى فيه طفرات تصير مرة بالعقار ومرة كذا ومرة كذا
اليوم الطفرة موجودة بالرياضة وبالسياحة وبالترفيه بشكل كبير جدًّا
صح
إذ أنك شركة تبغى تستفيد؛ لازم تمشي مع المجال
وإذا تقول والله مضيعة فلوس
راجع حساباتك
جميل، أنا ودي أختم الجانب التسويقي
في نوع من الحملات التسويقية اللي دائمًا تسوونها
سواءً مع البنوك أو مع تطبيقات المحافظ مثل «إس تي سي باي»
أو بنسميهم بنك الحين، متوجهين أنهم يصيرون بنك
اللي هو موضوع استرداد المبلغ
أنا ودي أعرف نموذج العمل في الشراكات هذه
هل اللي يتحمل استرداد المبلغ
البنك أو الشريك اللي معكم؟
أو أنتم تتحملون استرداد المبلغ، وللا مناصفة؟
لا، هي برامج لخدمة العميل
العميل مبسوط يرجع له جزء من اللي دفعه
وساعات يرجع كامل اللي دفعه
فتصير حراك تسويقي كويس له
طبعًا هي مشاريع مشتركة
فالتكلفة تكون موزعة بين الجهتين
بيننا كـ «جاهز» وبين البنك أو الجهة اللي معنا، مشتركة
كيف تكون مجدية بالنسبة لكم
إذا العميل قاعد يصرف ويرجع له نفس المبلغ؟
طبعًا مثل آخر حملة سويتوها
100% إلى 100 ريال طبعًا
فكيف تكون مجدية بالنسبة لكم مقارنة بالطرق التسويقية الثانية؟
والله شرحها صعب، بس لما تاخذ أي نشاط تسويقي
لو خذيته لقياسه ولوحده؛ بتكون خسران
أي شيء
اليوم أنت تبيع هذه القهوة
«خطوة جمل»
يبغى يبيع
لو جاء وحط حملة بـ 100 ألف
وجاء بكرة شاف مبيعات
وقال: والله بايعين 40 ألف
وأنا مسوّي حملة بـ 100 ألف، فأنا خسران 60 ألف
مو صحيح
الحملة هذه ترجع لك لفترة طويلة
اليوم لما أسوي استرداد المبلغ
بيجي عميل جديد يجيني لأول مرة
عشان يبي يستفيد من استرداد المبلغ
مثلًا هذا مثال بسيط
فيجي يدخل معك ويجيه استرداد المبلغ
فبيدخل لك مرة ثانية عشان يستفيد من استرداد المبلغ
جاك في المرة الثانية
90% بيتسمر معك للثالثة والرابعة والخامسة، هذا مثال
عميلك تكون نوع من السداد له،  أنك دفعت له شيء
عطيته شيء، برضه عميلك
سويت له شيء
عميلك جالس يشتغل معك
أو يدفع لك طول السنة
أرجع له مرة مبلغ
المشاكل اللي تسببها ما هي مزعجة؟
لأن عادةً فيها شروط تكون...
لا، طبعًا المشاكل قليلة ونسبتها قليلة
بس طبعًا في عالم تويتر
السبعة؟
لا، غير السبعة
في عالم تويتر المشكلة دائمًا
الصوت العالي للشكّاية أكثر من الباقي
المبسوط ساكت ما يقول شيء
المبسوط ساكت
وعلى فكرة وهذا عيب عندنا كثير احنا كناس
أخاف تمدحه يقول الإعلان وللا؟
لا، حتى بينه وبين نفسه ما يمدح
وأنا جربتها شخصيًّا
لما واحد يقدم لي خدمة وامدحه
تشوف النظرة بعيونه وتشوف شعوره
ترتاح نفسيًّا أنك فعلًا كنت صادق وأمين وكذا
مو متعود الظاهر
وكثير يمدحون الحمد لله، وكثير يثنون
وبالعكس يعني عملائنا حبايبنا
احنا بـ«جاهز» مع عملاء «جاهز» ترى صايرين عائلة
بس لأن طبيعة العروض هذه معقدة شوي
بس بعض المرات يكون واحد فهم غلط
وزعل واشتكى وبصوت يعني
بعض الكلمات اللي ما تحبها
مثلًا: إعلان مظلل، ما أدري شلون!
لا، يا أخي طيب
يعني خلنا احنا مع بعض
يعني لا تتجاوز بالعتاب
بشكل يصل لدرجة التشكيك في ذمة اللي قدامك
مثلًا في بعض الأحيان يصير
الحملة لحامل بطاقة «فيزا» مثلًا
وأنت جاي معك بطاقة «مدى»
صح
ودخلت ولا جاك استرداد المبلغ
تقدر تقول: والله ما شرحتوها بالشكل الزين
تقدر، بس لا تقول مظلل
لا هي ما مظلل، مثلها كذا
ما يقرون الشروط
إيه، بس عمومًا يعني الغالبية 99.99%
مبسوطين من العرض ومستانسين من هذا وغيره
والحمد لله، وعلاقتنا مرة ممتازة مع عملائنا
الحمد لله، ننتقل الآن إلى جانب آخر
كان ودي أتكلم معك فيه
يمكن ما تكلمت عنه كثير قبل كذا في لقاءات سابقة
اللي هي الشركات التابعة لكم
والنشاطات الثانية غير «جاهز»
نبدأها أولًا في منصة «بِك»
أنا ماني فاهم صراحةً ليش قررتوا تبيعون للمتاجر
اللي في منصة «بِك» برّا «جاهز»؟
ليش ما سويتوها داخل «جاهز»
وصار التطبيق اللي بتاع كله
يعني فيه كل الأشياء هذه؟
أول شيء أيش هي منصة «بِك»
للناس اللي ما مر عليهم المنصة؟
وليش فصلتوها عن «جاهز» وحتى باسم مختلف؟
أول شيء طبعًا «جاهز»
وهذا يعني كثير...
ويمكن الاسم، ويمكن كانت فيس بوك تعاني نفس الكلام
يعني فيس بوك صار معها شركات كثير
لما غيروا الاسم وصاروا ميتا
فبدت يسوون فرق بين فيس بوك وكذا
فـ«جاهز» تطبيق توصيل الطعام
هو اسم الشركة هو اسم التطبيق
فطغى على كل شركة «جاهز»
مع أن احنا نتمنى أن تطبيق التوصيل الطعام
ما يتجاوز 20% من حجم الشركة اللي هي «جاهز»
لما «بِك» ليش فصلناه عن تطبيق «جاهز»
عندنا نظرة، ما احنا مع شيء اسمه
ماهو الـ«ميقا ستور»
التطبيق الخارق
اللي هو تطبيق لكل شيء
إيه
ليش ضدها؟
ما أدري، احنا نرى أن التطبيق الخارق
وطبعًا هذا قابل للصح والغلط
بس احنا بـ«جاهز» واصلين قناعة أن التطبيق الخارق
ما هو نموذج كويس ممكن ينجح
زحمة
ولو نراجع مع بعض كم تطبيق خارق على مستوى العالم نجح
بتلاقيه قليلة جدًّا
فاحنا ضدها. وبنفس الوقت احنا كشركة
نعمل في هذا المجال ونعمل في التطوير
«بِك» ترى بدينا قبل الناس بثلاث سنوات على الأقل
أيش الهدف من إنشاءه كان؟
«بِك» هي فكرة جديدة
عمل جديد مختلف كليًا
«بِك» يمكن عشان أشرح لك
خل آخذ لك مسار التجارة الإلكترونية من وين بدأ
التجارة الإكترونية
التجارة الإلكترونية من بدايتها
أول ما بدت التجارة الإلكترونية
واحد عنده موقع يحط أسماء المنتجات
لما تنطلب، يروح لصاحب المنتج
مستودعاته اللي هو المكان
ياخذ منه المنتج
بعدين متعامل مع شركات شحن ويشحنه
ويوصل خلال شهر
وكان الناس مبسوطين عليه
بعدين صار فيه تطور
جاوا شركات التجارة الإلكترونية قالوا
ليه ما نحط مستودعات عندنا احنا
يصير عندنا مستودع في مكاننا الرئيسي
ونجمّع فيه بضائع العالم
فلما توصل الطلبات يصير بسرعة
ناخذ هذه المنتجات ونشحنها
فتوصل خلال أسبوع
فكان إنجاز كبير جدًّا
جاء تطور آخر
أنه ليش ما يصير فيه مخازن صغيرة
أو قبلها صار ليش ما يصير فيه مستودعات في المدن الرئيسية
وموجودة حتى الآن لو تلاقي «أمازون» تلاقي فيه مثلًا
تلاقي مخزنها بأمريكا ومخزن بدبي ومخزن بالرياض
فتلاقي بعض البضائع توصلك بأسبوعين
بعضها بأسبوع، بعضها توصلك خلال 24 ساعة
هذا مخزن في نفس المدينة فيخدم أكثر
الناس وطبيعة البشر كل ما لها تتغير
وكل ما لها الاحتياجات تزود وطلبات الناس تزود
صار أبو أسبوع هذا وين
يتأخر
أسبوع؟ يا ساتر
وللا حتى بكرة، أبيه الحين
إيه، فجاء شيء اسمه مخازن صغيرة
وشيء يسمونه التجارة السريعة
أنه والله يحطون مستودعات صغيرة بأكثر من موقع بالمدينة
فلما تطلب يأخذ من المستودع الصغير هذا يوصل لك
كأنه يوزّع مستودعات إلى داخل الأحياء بدل ما تكون...
فتوصل لك خلال ساعة أو ساعتين
كان هذا برضه قفزة كبيرة في عالم التجارة الإلكترونية
«بِك» جات بالخطوة اللي بعد هذه
طيب رجعت قالت
طيب ليش أصلًا أحتاج مستودع؟
ليش ما آخذ من المحلات نفسها؟
المحل نفسه أخليه هو المستودع
وأوصّل خلال ساعة
أيش فرقه عن التجارة السريعة؟
احنا سميناه على فكرة
سميناه التجارة المباشرة
المصطلح هذا طلع من «جاهز»
التجارة المباشرة مصطلح طالع من شركة «جاهز»
والآن بدأ يستخدم عالميًّا
حلو
فقلنا ليش ما نخلي هذا المحل هو المستودع ونخفف عليه
أيش فرقه عن التجارة السريعة؟
التجارة السريعة لما يصير عندك مستودع صغير
بتختار مجموعة أصناف، ما تقدر تجيب كل الأصناف
بيكون عندك مجموعة أصناف
مثلًا ألف صنف وللا شيء
هناك لا، لا محدود
كل اللي موجود في المحل؛ موجود عندي
فهذا الفرق
اثنين، مدام فيه مستودع ثاني
أنا باخذها من التاجر وأحطها عندي في مستودع
فبيكون فيه تكلفة إضافية
هذه التكلفة الإضافية؛ يا أتحملها أنا كتاجر، يا أحملها العميل
هناك ما في تكلفة إضافية
مباشر من المحل ونوديه
فشيء جديد
فهو بدل ما تسوي مستودع
وتجمع فيه الأصناف المتوفرة من أكثر من مكان مثلًا
تقول بآخذ من المتوفر بالمحل
بالمحل
بس هذا ما بيخلي الأصناف أقل إذا أنت بتاخذه من المحل؟
لا، خلاص أصنافك اللي بالمحل عندك باخذ منها
كامل الأصناف
إذا عندك المحل باخذ منه
ولا أكلّفك يا التاجر أي تكلفة إضافية تمامًا، ليش؟
لأن عاملك اللي موجود في المحل
ماهو يبيع للناس اللي داخلين عليه الوقت
ويجيه طلب مثل المطعم
ويجيه طلب يدخل عليه عميل عادي
بس كيف التجربة معكم هنا؟
أنا بقول لك
هذه تجربة جديدة
المتاجر لسه ما هم كلهم متعودين عليها
مو متعودين والله يخلي المتجر هو يبيع
فكان فيه معارضة بالبداية بشكل كبير
بدت شوي شوي تزود معنا المتاجر
نتوقع أنها بتضرب والقنبلة على قولتهم قريبًا
يعني مو أبعد من 2024 بتكون هي الأساس
لأنها بتاخذ عدد كبير
الناس خلاص ما يقبل أنه يتوصل له بـ 24 ساعة
هذا كثير
أتذكر أول ما بدينا حطينا شيرتات «الهلال» في «جاهز»
وهذه من ضمن الأفكار اللي خلتنا نروح لـ«بِك»
عميل مشتكي يقول صار ساعة ونص ما وصلني الشيرت
أروح أشتري من متجر «الهلال» أزين لي
كنت أقول لـ«غصاب المنديل»
ترى ناجحين إن شاء الله
ما دامهم بدأوا يتدمروهم ساعة ونص؛ حلو
كانوا شهر عادي
الآن ساعة ونص تفرق معاهم، فحلوة
ففكرة «بِك» مختلفة تمامًا
جالسين نغيّر سلوك الناس
وهو يتغير مع الوقت
اليوم يعني التسوق...
قبل فترة كنت بالرياض
إذا بتطلع أنت شاب وللا شابة
أهم نقطة تروح لمركز تجاري ترفيه وتنبسط
تمشية
تتمشى تروح للمركز التجاري
اليوم وأنت بالرياض
مجموعة شباب وللا مجموعة بنات
عندهم يا يروحون مطاعم، يا يروحون مقهى
وسينما وبوليفارد، ويروحون مدري وين
صار التسوّق ما هو ترفيه
صار فيه ترفيه صدقي ماهو ...
إيه، صار هذاك الترفيه
فصار هم وصار شغل
صح
فاليوم أنا بريحك، ليش تروح للمركز التجاري؟
بس هل تقدر تشارك...
وبنفس الوقت أخدم صاحب المركز التجاري
وهذه نقطة مهمة
صاحب المركز التجاري كان أحد أهم أعداءه التجارة الإلكترونية
أنه يا تشتري من التجارة الإلكترونية، يا تشتري مني
الحين أيش أقول له؟
بيشتري إلكترونيًّا بس منك
مش من مكان ثاني آخر
فبخدم صاحب المركز التجاري
والمتجر اللي داخل المركز التجاري
وأريح العميل
هل تقدر تشارك أي أرقام أداء *«البيكسون» عدد التجار؟
ما عندي أرقام واضحة صراحة الآن
تقديرية
ولا أحب أحط أرقام
لكن اللي أقدر أقوله
أن عدد المتاجر يزيد باليوم
عدد الأصناف تزيد باليوم
والمبيعات جالسة تزيد مش بالشكل اللي مرضينا بالأمانة
لكنها جالسة تزيد بشكل نوعًا ما مريح
لكن عارفين أننا ماشين بالخط الصحيح
ما تخشى أن السوق متوجه في التجارة
أن المحلات تبدأ تقفل وتفتح عبر الإنترنت
وتفتح لها مستودعات صغيرة
مثل المطابخ السحابية على سبيل المثال؟
هذا «بِك» يخدم المستودعات الصغيرة تمامًا
وهو أزين منفذ في المستودعات الصغيرة ويخدم المحلات
بالعكس احنا نتوقع أن «بِك» بيساعد ببقاء المحلات
أنه عشان إذا أنك موجود في مركز تجاري معين
ومبيعاتك مثلًا 70 ألف
وتحتاج توصل مبيعاتك 80 ألف عشان تقدر تستمر وتربح
ممكن نوصلك 90 ألف
بنفس متجرك، بنفس تكلفتك
بتبيع 70 ألف في مبيعاتك العادية ويزيد عليها إلكترونيًّا
ويستخدم نفسه؟
بنفس محلك ما يحتاج أي إضافات
ما يحتاج أي شيء إضافي
نفس محلك، نفس عاملك، نفس الكيس اللي تستخدمه
وهو يستخدم نفس مناديب «جاهز» وللا؟
هو الآن مش مناديب «جاهز»
الآن صار فيه لوجستيًّا ممكن نشرحها وقتها
صار عندنا شركة لوجستية الآن
بندخل عليها
تخدم حاليًا «جاهز» و«بِك» و«بلو»
وقريبًا بتخدم الجميع
جميل، نموذج عمل «بِك» نفس «جاهز»؟ نسبة وللا؟
إيه
تكون نسبة ثابتة على كل الطلبات
نسبة، بس هناك تختلف
عكس لما قلنا مطاعم نفس النسبة
هناك تختلف أنك ما تقدر مثلًا
تتعامل مع محل ملابس مثل محل جوالات
تلاقي هو أصلًا الهامش حقه محل جوالات ما يوصل
إيه، إلكترونيات
إيه، ما يوصل لـ 4% مثلًا
فما تقدر تقول أبغى آخذ منك 10% وللا كذا
وفيه محلات لا، هامش الربح كبير، فتختلف
فيه ناس تضيف له نسبة
إيه
حلو، طيب ننتقل على طاري المطابخ السحابية
على شركة المطابخ السحابية
أيش سميتوها يوم أطلقتوها؟
«كوكيتشن»
أيش سبب اطلاقكم للمطابخ السحابية؟
هل تبون تدخلون في منافسة مع المطاعم
وللا تبون تكملون المطاعم؟
احنا عمرنا ما راح نصير منافسين للمطاعم
ولو فكرنا يوم من الأيام ننافس المطاعم
معناته الخطأ الاكبر عندنا
احنا الذراع الرئيسي لنا هو المطاعم
ما نقدر ننافسه
بس المطعم اليوم نخدمه من خلال «جاهز»
طيب، يحتاج مساحات سحابية يتوسع فيها بطريقة أسهل
فليش ما أخدمه؟
فهي خدمة تقدم لهم
أنا جالس أخدمه فيها، جالس  أعطيه مجال ثاني
اليوم بدخل قريبًا في...
دخلنا بالطبع بالتمويل للمطاعم مثلًا
نساهم بالتمويل للمطاعم
تحتاج تمويل؟ أنا أقدر أسهّل لك العملية
لأني أخدمك أبيك تكبر
بس قبل التمويل
المطابخ السحابية الآن توفر للمطعم فرصة
أن يفتح مطبخ في منطقة جديدة
أن يتوسع بشكل أكبر
يعني اليوم مطعم موجود بالرياض مثلًا
يقدر يفتح ببريدة وللا بحائل وللا بالدمام بعد أسبوع
أيش نموذج العمل في المطبخ؟
يعني التكلفة الأساسية صفر
ما يتكلف ولا شيء
النتيجة أنه والله يجهز لك المساحة
ويجهز لك المكان كامل
ومجهز لك التوصيل عن طريق «جاهز» وغير «جاهز»
حتى فيه تطبيقات ثانية
إيه، وآخذ منك نسبة من عملك
بعت؛ أخذت منك
ما بعت؛ ما خسرت شيء
بس أنت عليك تكلفة برضه بتجهيز المطبخ
طبعًا، فأنا آخذ نسبة، أشاركه بنسبة نفس الشيء
بس أنا ما أشيل عنه موضوع التأسيس
يعني هو يجيك بصفر ما يدفع شيء؟
ما يدفع شيء
نهائيًّا؟
نهائيًّا
فقط يزيد النسبة
يدفع للـ«كوكيتشن» لما يبيع
إيه، فتاخذون نسبة إضافية علي...
لا، ما هو إضافية
«كوكيتشن» هو لحاله، و«جاهز» لحاله
«كوكيتشن» ياخذ نسبة
ياخذ نسبة من مبيعاتك
فهو ياخذ نسبة وأنتوا تاخذون نسبة في الحالة هذه كـ «جاهز»
إذا كان بايع عن طريق «جاهز»
لو جاك أحد اسمه غير معروف أساسًا
وما راح تجيه طلبات؛ فأنت خسران كذا
لا، هي تعتمد طبعًا بالشروط يعني لازم توصل مبيعات
ونسبة معينة بعد ثلاث شهور
وللا نقول له أنت خسران واحنا خسرانين
يعني لا نكمل مع بعض
نحاول ندعمه ونحاول نقوّيه
بس إذا والله مطعم مو قادر يبيع
يعني ما نستفيد احنا ولا هو أنه يستمر
أنتوا متى بديتوها هذه؟
من سنتين تقريبًا
هل منها مسويين مطعم «جاهز تحلّي»؟
والمتاجر هذا حقت «جاهز»
«جاهز تحلّي» والشغلة هذه
هي مش مطعم
هو خدمة للـ«كوكيتشن» هذا
فجايين عندك مجموعة مطاعم حلى أو محلات حلى، تمام؟
فطالع «جاهز تحلّي» يجمع جميع أصنافهم في قائمة وحدة
يسهل على العميل ويسهل لهم تسويقًّا
لكن هو مش مطعم فعلي، هو بس سحابي
هم موجودين داخل «كوكيتشن»
هو مثل المحلات اللي يجيبون حلى من الأسر المنتجة وكذا
إيه، بس هذولا يجيبون ويحطونها عندهم
هو ما عنده شيء
هو الآن داخل المركز حق «كوكيتشن»
خمسة أو ست محلات حلى، تمام؟
كل واحد طالع، بس مو موجود في «جاهز» مثلًا
«جاهز تحلّي» مختار أصناف من هذولا
حاطها في القائمة، بس ما في شيء بأرض الواقع
فهي ماهي منتجاتكم أنتم؟
ما هي منتجاتنا
إذا بعت خذيت منهم، جمعتها ووديتها
شركة «لوجي» اللي هي مناديب التوصيل كلهم يتبعون الشركة هذه؟
هي شركة الخدمات اللوجستية
اللي هي توصّل مفروض لـ «بلو» و«بِك» ولـ«جاهز»
لا، شوية معقدة العملية أكثر
اليوم فيه شيء اسمه «ساند»
هذا نظام يخدم «بِك» و«بلو» و«جاهز»
ومجهز وقريبًا سيطلق ويخدم أي جهة تحتاج توزيع
«ساند» مع من يتعامل كناس؟
يتعامل مع شركة «لوجي»
شركة «لوجي» شركة تدير عمالة توزيع، مندوبين توزيع
عندها حاليًا ألفين وشوي مندوب توزيع تحت كفالة «لوجي»
اللي هي مملوكة لـ«جاهز»
ويتعاملوا معها حوالي 300 شركة توزيع أخرى
يتعاملون مع «ساند» لتوصيل للثلاث شركات هذه الحالية
فهو نظام يدير عمليات التوزيع
والآن كل طلبات «جاهز» على سبيل المثال
أو تطبيق «جاهز» كلها عن طريق «لوجي»
لا، كلها عن طريق «ساند»
اللي هو النظام اللي يدير
لكن «لوجي» لها موزعين
بس «ساند» مو تبع «لوجي»؟
لا، «ساند» هو نظام إلكتروني يدير عمليات التوزيع اللوجستية
تبع مين؟
تبع «جاهز»
تبع الشركة الأم
والآن بيصير شركة لوحده حتى
النظام هذا يتعامل مع شركات تحتاج توصيل
وشركات عندها قدرة للتوصيل
من ضمنها «لوجي» اللي تبعكم
اليوم عندنا «جاهز» و«بِك» و«بلو» يحتاجون توصيل
وعندنا «لوجي» الشركة اللي نملكها
عندها قدرة التوصيل
وفيه 300 شركة توزيع أخرى ما نملكها
عندها قدرة التوزيع
كلهم مشتبكين مع «ساند»
لو بختصرها عشان بس أتأكد أني فاهم
منصة «ساند» تابعة للشركة الأم لـ «جاهز»
إيه نعم
وهي تربط ما بين الناس اللي يحتاجون الخدمة
مثل «جاهز» و«بلو» و«بِك»
خدمة التوصيل أو الشركات
وما بين مقدمين خدمة التوصيل
بالضبط
مثل «لوجي» اللي هي تبعكم
وشركات أخرى تقدم خدمة التوصيل
ليه شفتوا فيه أهمية أنكم تسوون شركة خاصة فيكم للتوصيل؟
احنا كتطبيق المفروض ما لنا علاقة بالتوصيل
مثل ما لنا علاقة بالمطاعم
يعني ما راح افتح مطعم وأسميه مطعم «جاهز»
وللا مطعم مش عارف أيش
لأن أنا جالس أخدم المطاعم
واستخدم الطرف الثالث اللي هو التوزيع
لكن عندنا بالمملكة
خدمات «الميل الأخير» فيها نقص كبير جدًّا من سنوات
من يمكن ثمان أو عشر سنوات، ولازال
فلازم يتعبى هذا
فاحنا جالسين الحين مضطرين نفتح الشركة ونجيب ناس
وفيها تكلفة، والعام الماضي كلفتنا مبالغ كبيرة
علشان تغطي جزء من تكاليفنا
وصاير فيه حراك على مستوى البلد
أن تغذية النقص هذا بخدمات «الميل الأخير»
عشان تتغطى بشكل كامل
فاحنا اليوم مضطرين نحطها فقط علشان تخدمنا
لكنها ماهي عملنا الرئيسي
لكنها جالسة تخدم عملنا الثاني
وتستخدم ناس على كفالتكم
إيه
بحيث أنهم يصيرون مناديب
إيه، جايبين ناس على كفالتنا وسيارات وشغل
من زمان وأنتم كذا وللا بديتوا تستخدموها؟
لا، من العام الماضي
بدينا فيها من العام الماضي عشان نغطي هذا الفرق
بنقص خدمات «الميل الأخير»
لأن عدد المناديب يا دوب يواكب الطلب المتسارع
أقل، طبعًا هذا مو بس بطبيقات التوصيل
كل شيء
خلني أذكرك بشغلة
أيش أكبر حدث يصير بالعشر الأخير من رمضان دائمًا؟
تويتر، وين يصير؟
لقطات على شركات النقل السريع
زحمة الناس راحين بالمستودع يبغون يجيبونه
الشكاوي: ما وصل طردي، ما وصل طردي
ماهو قصورًا بشركات التوصيل ترى شركات النقل السريع
نقص بالعدد، العدد بالمملكة قليل
نحتاج زيادة
يعني على الجانب هذا مثلًا
يجون بعض الناس ويقولون
نبغى نسعود القطاع هذا والتوصيل
طبعًا السعودة أنا معها 100% ودائمًا مع السعودة
ولو ترجع حسابي بتويتر تلاقيني دائمًا أطالب بالسعودة
لكن الجزئية هذه أصلًا فيها نقص
مو أن فيه زايد ونبغي نغطيه
فيه نقص
أنا ودي قبل ما ندخل في السعودة
خلنا نتكلم عن المندوب الآن
إيه
عشان الناس يقدرون يتخيلون الصورة بالكامل
المندوب الآن يبغى يوصل لـ«جاهز» أيش يسوي؟
وواحد ماله دخل في «لوجي»
جاك سواءً سعودي أو غير سعودي
يبغى يوصّل مع «جاهز» أيش يسوي؟
فيه أكثر من طريقة
ممكن يسجل عندنا في «جاهز» مباشرة هذا فقط للسعوديين
إذا سعودي أسجلك عندي في «جاهز»
من ضمن التوصيل في «جاهز»
وتصير مندوب تشتغل مستقل في «جاهز»
أو تروح...
بدون شروط، بدون شيء على طول تعال وسجل؟
شروط بسيطة: معك سيارة، معك رخصة، والأمور البسيطة هذه
وتشتغل على وقتك متى ما بغيت
إذا سعودي فقط سعودي تشتغل في «جاهز»
مندوب آخر؛ هذه 200 أو 300 شركة لوجستية هذولا
تقدر تشتغل معهم
هذولا بعضهم عمالة على كفالتهم
بعضهم عمالة مش على كفالتهم
بس وفق أنظمه معينة
المجال هذا جالس يتطور وجالس يُبنى
لأن هذا على فكرة أرضية لتطور كبير
اليوم وأنت بالتطبيقات جالس تتوسع وتشوف حجم العمل
فيه شغلات النقل السريع جالس تتوسع بشكل كبير
بس اسمح لي يا أبو عبدالله
عشان ما نطلع كثير عن النقطة هذه
الآن غير السعودي إذا ما هو على كفالة شركات التوصيل
هذا كيف يتم تنظيم عمله؟
هل لازم يكون يطلع رخصة عمل حر؟ وللا شلون؟
ما صار له تنظيم واضح تمامًا
اليوم مرحليًّا أنه يسجل معه الشركة التوصيل هذه
بموافقة كفيلة، وبشرط يكون كفيلة مش كفالة شخصية
مش عمالة منزلية، لازم يصير عامل شركة
فأنت عندك شركة وعندك عمالة زايدة
ممكن توافق تشغلهم
حلو طيب، عودةً على سعودة القطاع
اللي أنا ضده بالمناسبة، ماني معه
لا، الموضوع قصة السعودة
احنا كلنا مع السعودة
بس اليوم تتكلم على مناديب التوصيل
أو كما قلت لك خدمات «الميل الأخير»
اللي يوصّل، سواء لتطبيق، لشركة نقل، أو لغيرها
العدد أقل من المطلوب، ولازال نحتاج نزيد العدد
فيه مجال كبير للشباب السعودي يشتغل
بس طبعًا ماهي مهنة دائمة يعني يشتغل فترة ويمشي
وللمناديب، لازم نحتاج نجيب مناديب زيادة ونطورهم وكذا
بس يصيرون أكثر إحترافية، يكونون أكثر ...
بس ما شفنا شيء مناسب للسعودي أساسًا أنه يشتغل فيه
مناسب مرحليًّا
يعني يمكن يأخذ له قضية وقت
يعني الناس الدلوعين بعد
واحد طالب ومحتاج ماديًّا
لا، ممتاز. بس ما تقدر تقول
والله مثل ما بعض الأشخاص اللي اقترحوا
يقولك: لازم نسعود الأغلبية وللا 100%
مستحيل، ما تقدر
ما تقدر
حتى مع الأجانب ما أنت قادر توفي
الآن فيه نقص مع كل...
الآن فيه أجانب، وفيه ما هم محترفين تمامًا
ومع ذلك فيه نقص كبير
المفروض تزيد باحترافية المندوبين
سواء أجانب أو سعوديين
ولازال عندك مرحلة، يبي لك أربع أو خمس سنين
عشان يصير عندك كامل الطاقم محترف
السعودة، ما هي موضوع سعودة
لكن فيه مجال للسعوديين؟ فيه
تشتغل، ليش ما تشتغل؟
طالب ومحتاج ماديًّا
وللا حتى ما أنت محتاج
تبي تجرب؟
تشتغلك وتوصل لك طلبين، ثلاثة، أربعة، خمسة؛ اشتغل
جالس تبحث عن وظيفة شهرين ثلاثة بدل ما تجلس كذا
ممكن تشتغل، لكن ما هي وظيفة دائمة
وحاولنا على فكرة نخلق سوق من الشباب السعوديين
للعمل كمندوبين، طلعنا قصة كانت مجنونة
لو صارت أرقام كبيرة كما توقعها بعض الزملاء
كان ندفع يمكن مليارات
قلنا: يا مندوب، اشتغل يا شاب يا سعودي
اشتغل معنا سنة واحدة، بمعدل خمس طلبات باليوم
نهاية السنة نعطيك هدية سيارة
أوف!
طبعًا الحلقة بتنشر بعدين
بس بكرة عندنا حفل توزيع أربعين سيارة
ما شاء الله، توقعت العدد أكثر صراحة
أربعين سيارة
يعني أربعين واحد فاز فيها بالسنة هذه الأخيرة
قبلها يمكن وزعنا حوالي خمسين سيارة بس
يعني تسعين واحد اللي كمّل معنا سنة بمعدل خمس طلبات
بس إذا جاي يوم واحد وما وصل خمس طلبات، تروح عليه؟
لا، عادي
يعني المعدل
المعدل، فنقدر نعوضه بكرة
إيه، يمكن تريح يوم بالأسبوع
لكنك تجيب ست طلبات
أو يوم تشد عشرة أو خمسة عشر طلب
يعني لو تجيب ست طلبات باليوم
تحتاج تشتغل خمسة أيام بالأسبوع بس ووضعك بالسليم
سهلة مرة العملية، بس ما ألومهم
لأنه يشتغل معنا فترة ويوصل
وبعدين يحصل وظيفة
خلاص ما يبغي يصير مندوب ما يبغي يكمل، وغيرها
فهي ماهي مهنة دائمة
لكن بنفس الوقت أنا ضد لما يجي واحد يقول
لازم السعودة في القطاع كامل
مستحيل، ولا يصير
بس مرة ضد لما يجي واحد يقولك
يا أخي عيالنا ما نبيهم يشتغلوا مندوبين
ليش ما يشتغل؟ خليه يتدرب، خليه يعمل
حلوة، بس ما هي شيء تقول
هذا قطاع بستهدف سعودته
لا، ما هو قطاع ولا عملية وظيفة دائمة
لكن اشتغل لفترة تعلم، ليش لا
ممتازة جدًّا، قصدي ممتازة كخيار
ممتازة مؤقتًا؛ تفيدك بشغلات كثيرة
تعلمك، تقوّي عظمك شوي، تفيدك ماديًّا
تحتك بالناس
تحتك بالناس لفترة إلى أن تجد وظيفتك الدائمة
أنتم انتقلتوا على السيرة
بغطي على الجانب التشريعي في القطاع هذا
انتقلتوا من هيئة الاتصالات إلى هيئة النقل
هل نفس الآلية اللي كنتوا تشتغلون فيها مع هيئة الاتصالات
تشتغلون فيها الآن مع هيئة النقل وللا اختلف؟
طبعًا احنا قطاعنا أصلًا جديد
فأنظمته جديدة ومتداخلة مع أكثر من وزارة
هيئة الاتصالات، هيئة النقل، وزارة البلدية، وزارة الموارد البشرية
فلازالت تبنى الأنظمة بشكل دائم
بس جميع الجهات هذه متعاونة بشكل كبير الحمد لله
فيه تكاليف عليكم من الجهات الحكومية؟
لا، ما في تكاليف مباشرة
بس أن فيه تنظيم
وبعض الناس ما يحب التنظيم
التنظيم مهم للعمل، فيه تنظيم
وبعض التنظيم يؤدي إلى بعض المصاريف
لكن بشكل عام هو الفائدة في القطاع
شركة ثانية برضه -ما شاء الله- في المنظومة حق «جاهز»
اللي هي شركة الظاهر اسمها «اللون الأحمر»؟
«اللون الأحمر»
قطاع استثماري لكم
إيه، طبعًا خلنا أقول لك أيش هي «جاهز» بشكل كامل
الناس كل شوي يكتشفون شيء جديد
فيه «جاهز» الأم، تحتها تطبيق «جاهز» للطلبات
وفيه «لوجي» اللي هي الشركة اللوجستية
وفيه «بِك» اللي تكلمنا عنها قبل شوي
شركة تطبيق غالبًا يميل للنسائي أكثر
لكن هو مش أكل التطبيق
فيه «بلو» هو تطبيق شبابي رياضي
طبعًا فيه مفهوم خاطئ أنه متجر «الهلال»
وهو ليس متجر «الهلال»
يعني متاجر رياضية هذه
إيه هو متاجر رياضية ومتاجر عامة وشبابية
لكن هو تطبيق رياضي شبابي
لديه حصرية في منتجات «الهلال»
منتجات «الهلال» حصريًّا عنده، لكنه مش متجر «الهلال»
وفيه طبعًا «جاهز» بالبحرين، و«جاهز» بالكويت
وإن شاء الله قريبًا بأكثر من دولة خليجية
وفيه «مرن بيو إس» نقاط الكاشير
وكثير من شغلات التقنية المالية على خفيف
هذا اللي استحوذتوا عليها؟
إيه استحوذنا عليها وماشية
وفيه «اللون الأحمر» هذه الشركة استثمارية
تستثمر بمجالين: الآن مستثمرة بمجموعة
من الشركات الصغيرة والمتوسطة
باستثمارات بسيطة، يعني توزيع استثمارات فقط
وتستثمر ببعض الشركات اللي نبغى نتكامل معها
لبناء المنصة اللي نبغاها
اليوم مثلًا مشتركة في «اللون الأحمر»
«نعناع» مثلًا مستثمرين فيهم
هذاك استثمار بشكل كامل
لكن مثلًا مستثمرة بشركتين لوجستية قريبًا
يعني واحدة خليجية وواحدة سعودية
هذه الشركات اللوجستية احنا نستفيد منها بمنظومتنا
نحتاج لوجستك غير «لوجي» نحتاج شركات ثانية
مشتركة مثلًا اليوم مستثمرة بشركة
بتتزود المطاعم مبيعات الجملة بطريقة إلكترونية
فبحتكمل الصورة بشكل كامل
فهي «اللون الأحمر» خطها رئيسي
أما استثمار بحت استثمار للنمو فقط
أو استثمارات تفيد في الصورة الكاملة لشركة «جاهز»
لأن شركة «جاهز» جالسين نشوفها منصة كبيرة
فيها أكثر من خدمة متكاملة مع بعض
فـ 1+ 1 =4
استثماراتكم في مثل «نعناع» و«هلا»
هي تصب في مصلحة «جاهز» من ناحية إكمال المنظومة أو أنها؟
يعني بعضها كذا وبعضها كذا
مثلًا استثمارنا في «نعناع» مثلًا
هو الجزء الرئيسي استثمار
يعني بحت استثمار للاستثمار
لكن برضه فيه علاقات بيننا وبين «نعناع» كبيرة
ويمكن تشوف «نعناع» داخل تطبيق «جاهز»
يمكن لاحظتهم
فهذا من باب التعاون بين الشركات
لكن استثمارنا صغير يعني ما يأثر على قرارهم
أنهم يكونون معنا وللا ما يكونون معنا
هذاك كله علاقة خاصة
أنتم استحوذتم على «مرن» أيضًا بـ 60 مليون ريال
نعم
أيش سبب استحواذكم عليها؟
اللي هو نظام نقاط البيع
لأنه من ضمن المنصة هذه اللي نحتاجه
تبغون تكملون كامل الخدمات للمطعم
نبغى نكمل مو للمطعم
أو للمتجر
إيه، احنا نبغى نكمل كامل الصورة للتجارة الإلكترونية
وللا للاقتصاد الإلكتروني بشكل عام
فجالسين نتوسع بمجال كبير بالاقتصاد الإلكتروني
هذه جزء منه مهم. مهم أن نكون فيه
بنفس الوقت احنا نستثمر بعقول
يعني لما نستثمر بـ«مرن»
ويكون معنا مؤسسين «مرن» موجودين معنا الآن
جالسين نزيد عقول على الشركة
فيه مجال عالمي يمكن ما هو منتشر عندنا كثير بالسعودية هنا
لكنه عالميًّا معروف
أنه تستحوذ لتوظيف الفريق غير أنه للشركة
يعني تستحوذ لتوظيف الفريق
لتوظيف الفريق
فأنت جي تقول: والله فيه فريق ممتاز
يا أجي أحاول أغريهم أجيبهم كموظفين عندي
على واحد واحد ألقطهم، يا أخذ هذولا كلهم
الجمل بما حمل
الجمل بما حمل، فهذه مفيدة
مثل «مرن» فيها التنتين
فيها تكمل المنظومة حقتنا
وفيها في نفس الوقت جبت فريق متمكن متجانس
مرة وحدة صار من ضمن مجموعتنا
هل هذا يعني أن الخدمات اللي تقدم
للتجار داخل المحلات بمختلف أنواعها
هي قد تكون هدف استحواذ لكم مستقبلًا؟
مو شرط، يعني أنا ما أبغى أصير كل شيء لازم أشتغل فيه
بس اللي يمثل الصورة الكاملة حقتنا مستقبلًا؛ نمشي فيها
عندنا هدف وتوجهه كما قلت لك قبل شوي
لما أتكلم عن الأبطال الوطنيين
هذا هدف حكومي
فيه هدف حكومي لتكوين شركات مليارية
ويمكن سمعت عنه كثير
وكنا واحنا بـ«جاهز» نقول
احنا نبغى نمشي مع هدف حكومي
ونأمل نصير واحد من الشركات المليارية
والحمد لله صرنا
اليوم فيه هدف حكومي برضه
ضمن الاقتصاد المتكامل بالمملكة
أنه إنشاء شركات أبطال وطنية تنتقل إلى خارج المملكة
ففيه شركات بالطبع كانت قوية وجاهزة
أنها تصير الأبطال الوطنية
وفيه شركات يعني إحتمالية و«جاهز» وحدة منها
احنا ماشيين مع الهدف اللي يتوافق مع الهدف الحكومي
اللي نتمنى نكون جزء منه
بنكون نكسب احنا كشركة بشكل كبير
وبنفس الوقت نتوافق مع الرؤية اللي احنا فيها
احنا ترى، وهذه برضه أقولها للتجار وللشركات بشكل عام
احنا اليوم ماشيين ضمن رؤية عظيمة
رؤية سمو سيدي الأمير «محمد بن سلمان»
واحنا اللي قطعنا يمكن مشوار فيها
في الوصول إلى 2030
الرؤية هذه ترى ما هي شغلة حكومية فقط
الرؤية هذه تشمل: جهات حكومية، شركات خاصة، أفراد
حتى احنا كأفراد حتى جزء من هذه الرؤية
فاليوم أنت كشركة لما تحاول تكيّف نفسك للتوافق مع هذه الرؤية
تكون حصلت الحسنين
نجحت بشكل أسرع
وبنفس الوقت ساهمت ولو بشكل بسيط
بنجاح البلد اللي أنت فيه جميل ورؤيته
أنا قبل ما أطلع من جانب الاستثمار والاستحواذ
أبغى نتكلم عن موضوع مهم
اللي هو الاستحواذ على «ذا شفز»
«ذا شفز» يبدو أنه شكلًا على الأقل من برّا مثل «جاهز»
فأيش اللي خلاكم تهتمون بالاستحواذ عليه؟
جهتين: الأولى طبعًا أنت كشركة لازم تنمو بشكل سريع
ومطلوب منك أن تنمو
إيرادات وعملاء وكل شيء
والنمو شيء منه يسمونه طبيعي
النمو الثاني أنك تستحوذ
هذا يمارس وموجود على مستوى العالم
فهذه واحدة منها
أنه والله بنمو وبجيب شركات مشابهة أبغى آخذها
خذيت عملائها، خذيت مبيعاتها؛ نميت بشكل
يعني مو الشكل الطبيعي، لا
نميت بشكل أسرع، اللي هو عن طريق استحواذ
الكفاءات اللي بتستفيدون منهم
إيه، ليش «ذا شيفز»؟
بقولك: اثنين، فيها كفاءات برضه مميزة ونستفيد منها
ثلاثة «ذا شيفز» ترى حالة خاصة
من التطبيقات على مستوى المملكة
لو خذيت كل التطبيقات بجهة و«ذا شيفز» لوحدها
«ذا شيفز» جالسين يشتغلون *نيش لخدمات مميزة
اللي هم لطبقة أعلى
لطبقة شوي خاصة
لو أنهم بعدين بدوا ينزلون تحت عشان يتوسعون يكبرون
احنا نبغاها بهذه الطبقة
وهذا الكلام عن الطبقة أعلى ماديًّا
إيه، فالخدمة هذه المميزة
خلنا نقول خدمات كبار الشخصيات
هذه اللي بدوا فيها
يمكن الحين نزلوا شوي، بدوا يصيرون *ماس
لكن الجهة هذه بتفيدنا لما نخليها
شركة تشتغل بالمجال هذا
احنا مركزين في «جاهز» وبالباقي هذا
وفيه منافس كان نحاول يستحوذ عليهم قبلكم ولا قدر
بسبب تدخل هيئة المنافسة
هيئة المنافسة ما أتصور شافت أي مشكلة الآن بينكم
لا، لسه
هي طبعًا المنافس اللي تقول وكذا بالاسم
هو منافسنا الحقيقي على فكرة
أنت قبل شوي بالحوار
قلت: أحد الشركات اللي داخل السعودية منافسنا
هي ما هي منافسنا
احنا اللي ينافسنا حقيقيًّا بالمنطقة
هي شركة «دليفري هيرو» الشركة الألمانية
احنا نتنافس احنا وإياها
«دليفري هيرو» طبعًا شركة عالمية ألمانية
موجودة بأكثر مكان بالعالم
بس ليش «دليفري هيرو» مو «هانقرستشين»؟
لا، هي «ديلفري هيرو» اللي ينافسنا وليس «هنقر ستيشن»
بس «هنقرستيشن» هي الشركة الملكية
لا، بقولك
«دليفري هيرو»
اللي هي المالك الآن أصلًا
هذه موجودة بأكثر من منطقة بالعالم
موجودة عندنا في السعودية وموجودة بدول الخليج
«دليفري هيرو» شركة ماهي سهلة، قوية
استطاعت بأغلب دول الخليج
أنها تصير شبه حصري
طلعت جميع المنافسين
تمسك السوق بشكل كامل
تحرق السوق
بالسعودية استحوذت طبعًا على «هنقرستيشن»
«هنقرستيشن» أصلها سعودي، شركة سعودية
استحوذت عليها وحاولت تسوي نفس الشيء
وقفنا لها شوي بالحلق
الحمد لله ما قدرت تطلعنا
نافسناها، قوينا
اليوم طلعنا من السعودية
رحنا لها بالبحرين، رحنا لها بالكويت
فهي منافسنا على مستوى المنطقة
وهذا سبب يمكن أنه هيئة المنافسة اللي وقفتهم
أنه أنت شركة أجنبية قاعد تحاول تكوّش على السوق
يعني هم يحاولون كذا
طبعًا هيئة المنافسة لهم شروطهم وكذا
بس استغرب يوم كانت وقت يعني تداولات الاستحواذ
من «دليفري هيرو» على «ذا شيفز»
هيئة المنافسة طبعًا دائمًا يسوون الواجب حقهم
يشوفون جميع الأطراف وكذا ويحاولون يدرسون الموضوع
فمن ضمنها تواصلوا معنا بـ«جاهز»
كانوا يسألون عن *مرياتنا
فاجئناهم، احنا قلنا: بعكس يا أخي كملوا الصفقة
لا ترضون، احنا نرى أنه تكمل الصفقة
كنا وقتها نقول: رأينا بـ«جاهز»
أنه والله «ذا شفز» شباب سعوديين مجتهدين
عملوا شركة، لا تحرمونهم من البيعة، خلهم يروحون
وكانوا يقولون لنا الإخوان بهيئة المنافسة
أنه ممكن تضركم هذه
أتذكر أني كنت أسولف معهم فقلت
ما بنا خير إذا ضرتنا الصفقة هذه
احنا أقوى من أنها تضرنا
طبعًا هذه كانت توجيهات مباشرة من رئيس مجلس الإدارة
أتذكر قال لي: لا تلدّهم، خلهم يمشون
وأبدًا الله يوفق إن شاء الله الشباب
«عبدالرحمن الشبنات» و«عبدالرحمن المرشد»
والإخوان اللي معه بـ«ذا شفز»
واحنا والله ضعاف لدرجة
أن والله هذا الاستحواذ بيضررنا؛ ما بنا خير
ما تمت لأسباب أنا ما أعرفها
اليوم ترى إلى اللحظة هذه على فكرة ما اكتملت
أنتوا مددتوها لفترة...
لسه ما خذينا موافقة من هيئة المنافسة
ننتظر الموافقة لسه ما جات
ففيه احتمال انها ما تتم
إيه طبعًا
يعني كل الاحتمالات واردة
بسبب هيئة المنافسة أو بسبب شيء بينكم وبين «ذا شيفز»؟
لا، طبعًا هيئة المنافسة مجلس الموافقة
لأنه إذا طوّل الموضوع بعدين تطلع إشاعات
لا يكون فيه خلافات، لا يكون فيه مشكلة
لا، ما في إن شاء الله مشاكل
طبعًا تعرف الاستحواذ فيه عناية واجبة لازم يكمل
وفيه شغلات كثيرة وموافقات
فمن ضمن الموافقات؛ موافقة هيئة المنافسة
بعدين موافقة هيئة سوق المال
لأن فيها منحة أسهم، ماهي كلها نقد
فلازم موافقة هيئة سوق المال
وفيها عناية واجبة
كلها ماشية بالمجال
لكن إلى الآن احنا ما وصلتنا موافقة هيئة المنافسة
وإكمالًا لموضوع الشراكات
وإكمال كل الخدمات اللي تقدمونها للتجار
عندكم أيضًا شراكة مع «الرائدة» للتمويل
لتمويل التجار هي اللي ذكرتها قبل شوي صح؟
فيه أكثر من شركة للتمويل
طبعًا احنا شراكاتنا كثيرة جدًّا
مع جهات حكومية وجهات خاصة
بالتمويل، احنا عندنا شراكة مع بنك «منشآت»
لتمويل المطاعم والمتاجر، يتعاملون معنا
عندنا شراكة مع «فرص» برضه تمويل
وعندنا مع «الأمثل»
واليوم وقعنا مع «الرائدة»
فيصير المطعم يأخذ تمويل وتستقطعون من مستحقاته، صح؟
نضمن مستحقاته بطريقة أو بأخرى
طبعًا ما نستقطع رسميًا
يعني ما يحق لنا نستقطع من مبالغه عشان نسدد للجهة هذه
لكن مثل اللي نضمن بطريقة أو بأخرى
أو نعطي ضمانات معينة للممول
أن هذا والله ماشي وشغّال
فالمطعم اللي بيحتاج ياخذ تمويل من خلالكم
لا بد يكون فيه حركة معينة على حسابه؟
إيه، يعني على الأقل يصير يتوافق مع حجم عمله
وأيضًا فيه «ذيب» لتأجير السيارات
سويتوا معهم عقد توريد المركبات
إيه «ذيب» طبعًا العقد كبير اللي هو معنا بـ «لوجي»
«ذيب» و«باجيت» موقعين معهم
مع شركة «لوجي» اللي هي شركة التوصيل
اليوم ترى عندنا شركة توصيل تستغرب
مع أنها مو مشروعنا الرئيسي
لكن شركة التوصيل اللي تملكها «جاهز»
تعتبر واحدة من أكبر شركات التوصيل في العالم العربي
ما شاء الله تبارك الله
كعدد الأسطول، ولازال ينمو ويكبر
وبعض هذه ما تشيلون هم أنهم يروحون ويستخدمون تطبيقات منافسين
لا، ما تصير
شلون تضمن؟
ما شاء الله أشوف فيه مناديب بثلاث جوالات فاتح
هذولا الجزء الثاني اللي كلنا نبغى نتخلص منه
اليوم بالتوصيل بتلاقي جزء منظم
بتلاقي سعوديين، بتلاقي جزء منظم وجزء غير منظم
الغير منظم هذا؛ العميل يستاء منه شكلًا ومضمونًا
احنا الشركات نستاء منه، الجهات الجكومية تستاء منه
هذا جالسين كلنا احنا كتطبيقات مع الجهات الحكومية
نقلصه وإن شاء الله بأقرب وقت ينتهي
هذولي اللي ماسك ثلاث تطبيقات
اللي تلاقيه راكب له دباب، وشنطة وراء بلاستيك
هذول كلهم، ما أقول غير نظاميين
هو مقيم بالبلد صحيح، وموافق على عمله
ورقمه مسجل في هيئة النقل وكل شيء
لكنه ما هو مندوب توصيل محترف
كان النقاش هل نعمل أن يصير جميع طاقم التوصيل محترفين فورًا؟
كان هذا توجه بعض الجهات الحكومية
بس أنه مع اجتماعاتنا مع جميع الجهات الحكومية
كان أنه لو حاولنا نخليهم جميعهم محترفين فورًا
بنخفس بالسوق يمكن 80%
وتأثر مطاعم وتأثر متاجر
وتأثر مطاعم وتأثر سلسلة امدادات كثيرة ترى
اللي مستفيدين، شفت أنت ذكرت تو قبل شوي
«ذيب» وقلت لك «بجيت» معها
فيه اللي يوردون الأكل
فيه اللي يوردون الدعايات
فيه شركات الدعاية، فيه وفيه
سلسلة طويلة يعني صناعة كبيرة
فصار التوافق، أننا خلنا نتحول إلى عمل محترف
خلال ثلاث إلى أربع سنوات، وماشيين بهذا الخط
اليوم مثلًا عندنا بـ«جاهز»
بتلاقي عندنا عدد السعوديين لا بأس فيه
عندنا «لوجي» حوالي 2200 مندوب تبع كفالتنا
عندنا حوالي ثلاث أو أربع شركات
السعوديين كم عددهم؟
السعوديين يصلون حوالي 10 ألاف
بس انتاجيتهم شوي ماهي نفس غير السعوديين
طبعًا لظروف وكذا، فإنتاجيتهم ممكن مثل إنتاجية 5 ألاف
فعندنا شركتين استثمرنا فيهم
شغلهم منظم بعد ومرتب
وحدة اسمها «برق» يمكن تسمع فيها
وواحدة اسمها «بارسل» هذه شركة خليجية
وعندنا حوالي عشر إلى اثنا عشر شركة لوجستية منظمة
وجالسين نتساعد معها عشان يصيرون أكثر تنظيمًا بعد
يعني اليوم اللي يسمع وجاه فكرة
يؤسس شركة لوجستية ومحترفة
منفتحين أنتم تستثمرون؟
جدًّا، لا ما نستثمر
الاستثمار موشرط، يعني على حسب لهذه الأمور
بس تقول لي: أنصح أنك تكوّن شركة لوجستية أو «الميل الأخير»
أقول لك: أنصح بقوة، لكن يبغى لك طولة نفس شوي
لأن خلال هذه السنتين
لما يروحون غير المحترفين شوي شوي
بيبقى سوق منظم وفيه قطاع كبير
وفيه مجال كبير للنمو، ومجال مثمر ومفيد
صح، احنا تكلمنا عن منافس واحد اليوم
بس كيف تشوف مشهد المنافس بشكل عام؟
عندك مجموعة لاعبين
يمكن الأبرز أنتم «هنقرستيشن» «مرسول»
هذولي اللي دائمًا بالقمة، نسمع عنهم دائمًا
بس فيه أيضًا «تو يو»
وفيه «ذا شيفز» طبعًا لأنهم مستهدفين عدد أقل من العملاء
وفيه «مستر مندوب» مسوي شوي زحمة الفترة الأخيرة
ويحاول يلعب على جانب النسبة
سواءً حق المناديب أو المطاعم، حسب ما أذكر على الأقل
فكيف تشوفون مشهد المنافسة؟ هل أنتم بس...
هو السوق كبير ويسع الكثير
طبعًا ذكرت مجموعة من الأسامي
أكثر اللي ذكرتهم شركات مميزة وكويسة
لو أنا من خارج القطاع ممكن أستثمر فيها مباشرة
وبعضهم لا
يعني المشروع التجاري يحتاج عمل صحيح
أنك تعمل بشكل صحيح، وليس تدّعي أنك تعمل
فكثير من هذه الشركات اللي ذكرتها
بالعكس شركات سعودية مميزة
وأتوقع لها نمو وتكبر
والمجال كبير
لازال حتى فيه مجال أنها تدخل شركات جديدة على هذا السوق
السوق كبير مرة ترى مو صغير
جميل، تجربة الطرح كيف كانت؟
أفضل وأجمل وأسوأ وأصعب قرار
الحين بعد ما مر الوقت هذا كله
ما تحس أنه كان المفروض تأجل
كان مثلًا ممكن تشوفون شيء في...
تغيرون شيء في التقييم، في السعر
يعني في أي جانب
لا، بالمجال هذا هو أصعب
أجمل، لأنك تخارج بطريقة جديدة
على الشركات التقنية ما كانت موجودة
قبل هذا الطرح حق «جاهز»
أي شركة تقنية تبني، تشتغل
تنتظر أنه يجيها شركة دولية تشتريها
هذا أملها، تتخارج
إيه، أنا متأكد على المستوى الشخصي لكم ممتاز
بس فيه ناس...
بقولك هنا بهذه الجزئية
فصار فيه تخارج كويس
أجمل، أصبحت شركة ضخمة، شركة كبيرة
أصبحت شركة لها تقييمها، لها تقديرها، لها احترامها، وهذا مهم
أصعب، لأنه قبل كان القرار بيد ثلاثة، أربعة، خمسة أشخاص ملاك
أسهل يعني الحركة أسرع
لكن بطأكم شوي
يعني نوعًا ما فيه قوانين
فيه شغلات شوي صعبة
أسوأ، أنك قبل مهما تشتغل تحس أنك والله أنا أشتغل وبحلالي
وباقي الشركاء قريبين مني
رحنا يمين، رحنا يسار
ما يصير هذا الهم عليك
اليوم ممكن فيه واحد مالك بجنوب أفريقيا ويملك عندك
فأنت تبغى يعني شايل هم أنه يكون راضي عليك
أو على الأقل أنك أنت مؤدي الأمانة له
لأن هو مستأمنك على الشغل هو بجنوب أفريقيا
وللا بأمريكا وللا ببريطانيا وللا بالسعودية أو بأي مكان
ترى على فكرة ملاك «جاهز» الغير سعوديين
الجهات الغير سعودية
«جاهز» قد تكون رقم اثنين أو ثلاثة
بعدد المستثمرين الأجانب في شركة سعودية
ورقم واحد «أرامكو»
فهذا عشان تعرف الحجم
خلنا نقول تعليقات بعض الناس
أيش تقول عليهم سبعة أو ثمانية اللي هم
قالوا: أنه مع انخفاض قيمة السهم تقريبًا 60%
أنه يمكن «جاهز» طرحوا بتقييم مبالغ فيه
أول شيء، ترى مو «جاهز» اللي تقيّم، هذا واحد
لما نقول تقييم، ترى ما أنت بتطرح في السوق
تجي تقول: أنا والله سعري ألف السهم، يلا
مو بأنت تختار
التقييم يأتي عن طريق بيوت خبرة وبنوك ومستثمرين
هم اللي يقيمون ويطرح قيمة السهم
اثنين، النزول مو 60%
نزل شيء بسيط، ويمكن النزول الأكبر
اللي قريبين من السوق يعرفونه
بس اللي بعيدين ما يعرفونه
أنه والله تركيبة «جاهز» كان فيه مجموعة مستثمرين
صندوق استثمر في «جاهز» قبل الطرح
هذا الصندوق فيه عدد كبير لا بأس فيه
يمكن مئة شخص، ما أدري كم عددهم
على هذه الحدود
هذولا استثمروا اللي بـ 500 ألف، واللي بمليون
ومبالغهم تضاعفت عشرين وخمس عشرين مرة بعد الطرح
فأنت تخيل أنك مساهم بـ 500 ألف
صار عندك 20 مليون مثلًا
جتك فرصة أنك تبيع
فتخارجوا
تخارجوا، ولو يطلع بنص القيمة
هو كسبان مكسب كبير
فطلعوا عدد كبير منهم
لكن الرقم، خلني أعطيك قصة
يمكن من النوادر بالشركات
تلاقي مؤسسيين يشترون بعد الطرح
أنا شخصيًّا مشتري بعد الطرح
ليش؟
يوم نزل السهم؛ شفت أنه مغري واشريت
أنا مشتري بعد الطرح، بعد النزول
برضه عندك نقد ودّك تصرفه
الفكرة أنه لسه «جاهز» أكبر بكثير من كذا
بس سعرها ينزل يطلع
طبعًا عاد على قولتك بتويتر وكذا
وفيه بعض عاد اللي ممتعين يقول لك
«جاهز» سهمها 850 و «أرامكو» ثلاثين
شلون أغلى من «أرامكو»؟
إيه، لا ماله دخل فيه
ما تقدر تقيس على سعر السهم
بس هو على الأداء أنه فيه ناس يقولون
أوه شكله كان مبالغ فيه
ليش انحاشوا المستثمرين؟
تعرف اللي تصير سالفة؟
بس في تويتر طبعًا تكبر هذا القد
طبعًا هو السبب الرئيسي أنا أعتقد كما قلت لك
أن مجموعة المستثمرين اللي دخلوا كصندوق
وكسبوا مبالغ كبيرة وطلعوا
أصلًا يوم نزولها هي يوم توزيع الصندوق
يوم وزع الأسهم على مُلاك الصندوق
بس برضه فيه ناس يستشهدون
ما بقول أنه صح أو خطأ
بس بجيبها كجزء من السالفة
أنه صار فيه انخفاض كبير أيضًا في الأرباح
في نهاية السنة الماضية
كان جزء منه أو السبب الأساسي اللي ذكرتوه
أنه كان لأرتفاع أسعار التوصيل
أو تكاليف التوصيل والجهات الحكومية
هذا ما أذكر الصيغة
لا، أنا بعطيك سالفة، بعطيك قصة
طيب جاوبني على...
لا، بعطيك قصة وتجاوبك على هذا السؤال
اتنين إخوان جاء أبوه وأعطاهم بيتين شعبيين، حلو؟
و 100 ألف
كل واحد قال له: خذ 100 ألف وخذ بيت
واحد أجّر البيت بـ 10 ألف
الثاني هد البيت، وأخذ قرض من البنك مليون
وبنى له عمارة
نهاية السنة، جاوا يشوفون أرباحهم
الأول اللي أجّر؛ كان رابح 10 ألف
وما شاء الله عنده أرباح
الثاني خسران
دفع حق البنك يعني اللي يدفعه خلال السنة 100 ألف مثلًا
كان خسران 100 ألف
السنة الثانية راعي البيت الشعبي أجّر بـ 10 ألف ثانية
فربحان 10 ألف، صار عندي 120 ألف مبسوط
هذاك خسران 100 ألف ثانية، لازل يبني
السنة الثالثة هذا أجّر بـ 10 ألف
الأخ الأصغر اكتملت العمارة وأجّرها بـ 600 ألف
العام الماضي اللي يتكلمون على خسارة
لما تشوف «جاهز» لحالها
«جاهز» لحالها أرباحها العام الماضي أعلى من اللي قبلها
لكن الأرباح هذه خذتها
وصرفت في «بِك» وفي «بلو»
و«جاهز» البحرين، و«جاهز» الكويت وفي «لوجي» حلو؟
حلو
فصرفت كل هذه المبالغ
ربحيتي أقل، وصرفت
ترى على فكرة لو نشتري شركات جاهزة
ما تعتبر مصروف، فما تبين بالربح
لكن احنا ننشئها من الصفر
فيبين أنها خسرانة
لكن الصحيح أنك جالس تستثمر في مجالات أخرى
إيه، طبيعي هذا يكون عائدها على المدى البعيد
فتشوف السنة هذه تقولك خسرانة، مو خسرانة
بتفسيري مو خسرانة، بغض النظر على تفسير...
بس كان برضه فيه ارتفاع في تكليف التوصيل مقارنة بالسابق، صح؟
لا، تكاليف التوصيل تزود وتنقص
ماهي هي السبب
ما صار في...
لا، التكاليف الرئيسية كانت في تأسيس «لوجي»
«لوجي» الشركة اللوجستية كلّفت واجد
طبعًا فيه جزء منها اللي هو غير متكرر
إيه، فهي جزء يعني...
إيه طبعًا بس هذه أننا جالس أنشئ الشركة
لكن جزء منها، يعني صرفنا بـ«لوجي» ممكن أكثر من اللازم
لسبب أنه جبنا سواقين عشان نشغلهم؛ خذينا وقت أطول
عشان تطلّع رخصة يبغى لك ثلاثة أو أربعة شهور
بعض الأمور اللوجستية تأسيسها شوي صعبة
فصرفنا أكثر من اللازم فيها
لكن بشكل عام، احنا طلعنا من السنة
وعندنا «لوجي» و«بِك» و«بلو»
وعندنا «جاهز» بالكويت، و«جاهز» بالبحرين
فجالس تتوسع
لكن بشكل عام تقول لي
والله «جاهز» اليوم، و«جاهز» قبل سنتين
«جاهز» اليوم أكبر
حلو، هنا يمكن يقودنا إلى المحور الأخير اللي نتكلم فيه
اللي هو وين رايحين «جاهز»؟
وين تشوفون نفسكم مثلًا بالسنة الجاية؟
اللي بعدها، إلى خمس سنوات قدام
مش الأشياء اللي بتستثمرون فيها
بدون طبعًا ما تخالف قوانين هيئة سوق المال
بس وين متوجهة «جاهز»؟
أنت قلت لي مثلًا
ما تبغى تصير تطبيق خارق في «جاهز» التطبيق
لا، كتطبيق خارق احنا ضده كمبدأ
لكن احنا نستثمر بالتطبيقات بشكل عام
خلني أقول لك جهتين
«جاهز» المشهور اللي هو التطبيق
نبغاه يكبر ويتطور وتزود خدمات عليه
وجالسة تزود كل شوي
حتى تدخل عليه مثلًا خدمات «اشتر الآن واجفع لاحقًّا»
تحملونها على التاجر وللا؟
تتوزع بطريقة عادلة إن شاء الله
أكثر من خدمة بتدخل فيه قريبًا
فهو المفروض أنه يكبر
اثنين، عندنا هدف رئيسي
أن «جاهز» هذا التطبيق المدلّع اللي هو البطل حقنا
أنه ما يمثّل أكثر من 20% من «جاهز»
هذا هدف رئيسي عندنا
اثنين، شلون نتوسع جغرافيًّا
يعني أفقيًّا ورأسيًّا على قولتهم
جغرافيًّا رحنا لدولتين من دول الخليج
وبنروح إن شاء الله لدول أكثر
ورأسيًّا نبي نشتغل بأكثر من مجال
يعني مثل ما قلنا بدينا بالتطبيقين
لكن فيه خدمات ثانية
خدمات تقنية مالية، خدمات لوجيستية
فجالسين نطور فيها بعد
لكنه لما أعطيك شكل عام
هدفنا أنه ما يصير «جاهز» التطبيق
أكثر من 20% من «جاهز» الشركة
حلو، وما أتصور فيه أشياء...
من أشياء اللي ذكروها الناس دائم
وأحس أنها غير منطقية
ولا راح تسويها أي وقت قريب
اللي هو التوصيل من خلال الطائرات المسيّرة مثلًا
أحس أنها مجرد فكرة
شوف خلني أكون واقعي جدًّا فيها
واحد يقول لك: التوصيل خلال الطائرات المسيّرة
بيصير قريبًا؛ هذا حالم
واحد يقول لك: لا، يا رجال اترك الطائرات المسيّرة
ولا تقرب لها وهذه بعدين؛ هذا إنسان غير واقعي
احنا أيش جالسين نسوي اليوم؟
احنا ندري، أنا على المستوى الشخصي واحنا بالشركة ندري
أن التوصيل عن طريق الطائرات المسيّرة بياخذ الوقت
لأن الموضوع ما هو بس طائرة مسيّرة تمشي وتتحرك
الموضوع قصة طويلة، الموضوع شبكة كاملة
الموضوع اليوم عشان تحرّك طائرة مسيّرة داخل الرياض مثلًا
لازم فيه مسارات، المسارات هذه من يمنحها؟
جهة حكومية تمنحها، ولها رخص
ووقت اقلاع ووقت هبوط على الأقل، واستخدام المسار
تفاصيل كثيرة وقوانين لسه لجالسة تنبني
يبي لها وقت
لكن تجي تقول: لا والله طائرات مسيّرة بعدين
وتحط يدك كذا وتكتّف يديك ولا تسوي شيء؛ غلطان
احنا أيش جالسين نسوي بـ«جاهز»؟
اليوم احنا عندنا «آر آند دي»
بحوث بالتنسيق مع جامعة الملك «عبدالله» في «رابغ»
شغالين على بحوث لعمليات الطائرات المسيّرة
أو حتى السيارات الصغيرة اللي تتحرك لوحدها
فجالسين نشتغل معهم
تبون تكونون مستعدين للمستقبل يعني
جالسين نبغى نصير جزء من هذا المستقبل
ندري أنه مو بكرة، بس يمكن يتسارع قريبًا
فاننا لو نجي ندّعي نبي نشتغله بكرة؛ نكون حالمين
لو نجلس الناس بتسبقنا
فجالسين نشتغل فيها
زائد في شركة برضه أمريكية
عندنا احنا وياهم تواصل
وعندنا نوع من الدراسات بهذه
وبتجينا برضه بعض الأجهزة وبعض الأدوات
اللي بنستخدمها بالتجارب هنا بالمملكة
خصوصًا بعض الأماكن المغلقة
مثل مثلًا مدينة «الرائدة»
مكان مغلق ممكن يسير فيه
فبرضه شغالين فيها
جميل، الله يعطيك العافية أبو عبدالله
طولنا معك اليوم، لكن ما شاء الله قاعدين ننبش
نعرف «جاهز» أيش عنده بالضبط اللي هي الشركة الأم
صراحة انبهرت في المعلومات اللي عرفتها منك
من كثر الأشياء اللي تسوونها
حتى ما في مجال أننا نناقشكم مستقبلًا
شكلكم وصلتوه ما شاء الله
لا استثمار، لا استحواذات، لا تفاصيل كثيرة
أعتقد بيستفيد منها كثير
للناس العاملين في السوق
سواءً تجار، سواءً رواد أعمال
سواءً كانوا مستثمرين
فشكرًا لك على وقتك
نورتنا اليوم وأثريتنا صراحة
الله يسلمك ويخليك
بالعكس سعيد أني أكون معك
وتعرف كما قلت لك بداية اللقاء أنا
تعرف رأيي شخصي بك
الله يرفع قدرك
ثقتي فيك، وعشان كذا انبسطت وجيت معكم
يمكن أختم بشغلة واحدة
بـ«جاهز» أنا أعتقد أنها تجربة ناجحة الحمد لله
وتجربة مثال
وأنا الصراحة فخور أني جزء منها
وأعتقد أن النجاح مو لمجموعة أفراد
نجاح لشباب سعوديين كان عندهم طموح
كان عندهم إيمان بقدراتهم
وإيمان بقدرات هذا البلد اللي احنا فيه
فالحمد لله، اليوم أنا فاخر
لما نجلس مع شركات أوربية وللا أمريكية
وللا صينية ونتكلم معهم
لما تسمع الثناء اللي يجينا منهم على «جاهز» وتجربة «جاهز»
والله يعني رقبة الواحد تطول
بس مو لأني أنا بـ«جاهز» لأني أنا سعودي
قدرنا الحمد لله كشباب سعوديين
نكسّر حواجز كثيرة، تخلينا فعلًا نعيش بالفخر
شغلة ثانية، أننا برضه محظوظين
ولا هي والله مجاملة ولا هو كلام للتسويق
لكن فعلًا اليوم احنا كشباب سعودي
بهذا البلد المعطاء محظوظين
لولا توفيق الله سبحانه وتعالى ثم دعم الكثير
من ضمنهم كثير من الجهات الحكومية
ما وصلنا للي وصلنا له
يعني «من لا يشكر الناس لا يشكر الله»
وزارة اتصالات، هيئة الاتصالات
وزارة النقل، هيئة النقل
وزارة الموارد البشرية، وزارة البلدية، وزارة الصحة
كثير من الجهات ساهمت في دعمنا
وخلتنا نوصل للي وصلنا له الحمدلله
ووضوح الرؤية نفسها أصلًا
يوريك وين رايحة الدولة ووين تقدر تستثمر فيها أساسًا
بالضبط
على أساس تكون ماشي مع القطار
أيوة وأمشَّ، الأمور مفتوحة لك؛ أمشَّ
والرؤية واضحة قدام
خلّك جزء من هذه الرؤية؛ توصل لهناك
بتساهم وبتستفيد أكثر
وهذا على مستوى الأفراد والشركات ومستوى كل شيء
الله يعطيك العافية أبو عبدالله ما قصرت
يعافيك، تسلم
شكرًا لك
شكرًا لكم
وشكرًا لعبدالملك آل سعيد في إنتاج المحتوى
في التحرير مرام الضبيبان
في إدارة التصوير ياسر بن غانم
في الإضاءة عبدالمجيد عمر
في الهندسة الصوتية عبدالعزيز المزي
في الإخراج الإبداعي وهاب موسى
في الإخراج الفني مجد الملّي
ومساعده وسيم معين
وفي الإنتاج التنفيذي غيداء التميمي
هذا بودكاست سوالف بزنس
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع